does the is the sound working the sound
is working well I'm a little blown out
here it's very very bright we're coming
to you live from the Congressional
offices of congresswoman Lauren bobert
we are in the capital and we're going to
have an awesome uh array of guests to
talk about a lot of what's been going on
so the other day of course we had the
State of the Union Address from Joe
Biden which was interesting to me it
sounded like a lot like another campaign
speech where he actually said a lot of
things were really bad that was
surprising like this person's dying of
cancer and this person you know there
was a mass shooting and this bad thing
happened and this is police brutality
and I found it interesting that he
talked about really bad things but then
went on to say don't worry things will
get better
I do find that interesting so we'll talk
about that while he was speaking he lied
about several things and was booed by
members of the Republican party and then
of course we had today a hearing with
the Twitter Executives from before Elon
Musk and we had some I think Justified
questions as well as some performative
outrage so we're going to be hanging out
with a slew of Republican members of
Congress to talk about just about
everything and uh I got to tell you guys
I I hope you can hear it I hope it's
coming in Serge and and Andrew were able
to put this podcast Studio together in a
matter of a couple hours we like Rush
from the studio bring it down there's
cameras and everything set up and I
gotta admit it was quite difficult some
things weren't working but I think we
figured out to a good enough degree that
we're actually going to be able to do a
show but we're probably not going to
have any any Clips or displays or
articles we're going to talk about
what's going on so it should be fun
thank you all so much for joining us and
become a member at timcast.com to
support our work we're gonna have a
members only show of course tonight at
least that's the hope so we'll be here
late at the Congressional offices but as
a member you're supporting our our
cultural work as well as getting access
to our uncensored members only segments
so again smash that like button
subscribe to this channel joining us
tonight we have sitting with us right
now is congresswoman Lauren bobert
hey everyone so great to be here thanks
so much for joining us here in
Washington DC in my congressional office
this is fantastic this is kind of crazy
yeah yeah oh thanks
in here we just had to undo everything
oh cool nice it totally worth it it's
very cool and thanks for inviting us
this is kind of kind of wild we we came
up with it like the last minute on
Friday your Communications people were
like hey come and build a studio down
here and I was like okay that sounds fun
so creative I love it yeah so do you
want to introduce yourself briefly for
those that who I know I think everybody
knows who you are but
sorry her audio is really low do you see
that
no audio uh-oh bring it up what about
that microphone you see this is what
happens when you build a pike Lauren
bobert is the congresswoman of Colorado
uh what's what I'm not going to speak
for you the whole show yeah how was that
that's weird I can hear it Marco
what
oh yeah and and Hannah no audio on your
monkey I think either
nope
this is what this is what happens when
you try to set up a podcast studio in
two hours I told you guys I said I'm
surprised we got half as good as we did
you know what you want to switch seats
with me in the meantime Lauren let's
here come over here
here we get we got Sam cool well I'm
talking that worked
and and the light is so much brighter
over here too for some reason
all right there's there's
all right now you can introduce yourself
all right well I am congresswoman Lauren
bobert and I represent Colorado's Third
District so I'm on the the western slope
of Colorado uh that's where I live and
uh you know it's a fantastic District I
represent about half the state of
Colorado uh and it's a beautiful country
uh unfortunately uh you know a lot of
Californians have come into Colorado and
have been taking over uh but I I didn't
want to be in politics that wasn't my uh
inspiration ever in life I'm a mom of
four boys I was a small business owner
owned a few restaurants one of them had
a lot of national notoriety Shooters
Grill all of the waitresses open carried
firearms and we had that for about nine
years and uh you know I just got
frustrated at politicians uh you know
they would say one thing on the campaign
Trail and then they would get to where
we send them and they would do something
completely different none of them would
govern as they campaigned and so that
frustration really led me to say you
know I'm gonna do my part to serve I'm
gonna step up and do what I can to make
make things right and get our country
back on track so I'm here this is my
second term in Congress and it's it's
been amazing to to stand up for the
people to fight for the people and
there's been some really fun fights that
we've had yeah there's pictures of you
yelling at the president I think
yeah a little bit well you know when
when gosh Joe Biden was um going to
completely skip over the 13 American
Heroes who died on his watch in
Afghanistan and I wasn't going to let
that happen and so I was sure to remind
him that he sent them home in flag
draped coffins 13 of them and even his
uh press secretary at the time his spin
doctor jensaki she came on the next day
to say that he didn't have time to talk
about them he said you know that that's
really evident actually because he
didn't have time for them when they were
brought home to Dover either so it's
total disgrace and actually last night
at the State of the Union again he did
not mention these 13 American Heroes who
died on his watch from that horrible
shameful withdrawal in Afghanistan
no we can hear it but it's not coming
through
nobody can hear you
yeah because what he's saying is good no
it was a surrender you're absolutely
right
um that was a surrender to the Taliban
and we left 86 billion dollars in
military equipment the finest military
equipment in the world right there in
the hands of the Taliban uh you know I
think rather than sending Ukraine 110
billion dollars we should be going and
getting that military equipment instead
of sending Ukraine tanks and and the
fighter jets that they're wanting well
let's go get that stuff help them out
with that what is it
it's the cables bed
well nobody can hear you Ian so it's
like Ian's desperately trying to talk to
people maybe maybe it's what's going on
okay well well look ladies and gentlemen
uh as I stated we we rushed down to DC
it's like an hour and 10 or so minutes
drive and then Surge and Andrew quickly
rep put this whole thing together
everybody can hear Ian and Hannah clear
in the headsets but for some reason it's
not coming through you guys but we're
gonna have a uh either way it'll be fun
because not only do we have
congresswoman uh Lauren bobert sitting
right here taking ENC for the time being
but uh Jim Jordan's coming down yes
Byron Donald's Anna Paulina Luna yes
Matt Gates Matt Gates yes so uh we'll
just talk about all this stuff and it's
going to be somewhat different from how
we normally do things because normally
we do segments we have we have Clips we
have you know articles and stuff to pull
up but I think for now considering the
technical difficulties we should just uh
talk is that is that Matt Gates is in
the chat
so uh well let's just let's just hey
Matt let's just get started while they
try and fix these uh uh microphones and
I suppose we'll just talk uh sure uh
congresswoman so uh what should we start
with should we start with the state of
the union or the Twitter stuff what do
you think oh gosh there's so much to
start with I mean we started this whole
year with an explosive
um debate and it hasn't stopped we
haven't slowed up
um so sure let's talk about the State of
the Union State of the Union so here's
what we watched it live we provide a
commentary I do think one of the
funniest things about it is that Jack
pesobic leaked the script his entire
script in the middle of his speech so
we're watching we've got 40 some odd
thousand live viewers at the time and
I'm reading his words before he even
says them which I I get it they have
speech writers but it really did make it
feel so much more plastic like someone
wrote this forum and he was just saying
whatever it it didn't feel real it felt
to me like he was saying a bunch of bad
things were happening yes yes he was
police brutality killed this person you
know uh he didn't mention people are
smuggling eggs over the Mexican border
but he said a lot of don't worry we will
do things in the future his party has
been in power uh for the past two years
and they've done nothing but destroy our
country and make it worse and increase
inflation and and open our borders uh so
why didn't they do it then you know
we're battling this in committee right
now on natural resources and oversight
Democrats are saying uh you know we want
to work to do this we want to work to
secure the border and have immigration
reform well why didn't you do any of it
in the last two years you had every
ability to pass whatever you wanted and
you didn't and Tim I kind of wish I
would have had his script because Matt
Gates and I were sitting together on the
house floor and we were wishing that uh
Joe Biden would just turn around the
teleprompter so we could read it
ourselves because half the time we're
saying what did he just say yeah well we
think he's talking about big Tech I
don't know there was a crazy point where
he said you could see in the closed
caption he said if Republicans try to
raise the cost of prescription drugs I
will veto it but what he actually said
was was if Republicans try to return
I'll veto it yeah and the Democrats all
stood up and started clapping for it and
I was like what did he just what are
they clapping for
can is it I don't Ian's trying so hard
to talk we'll see what y'all couldn't
see were the Applause lights flashing
yeah so
but let me let me ask you about uh one
of the most contentious moments he said
that Republicans want to do away with
Social Security Medicare Medicaid and
then immediately the Republicans start
booing and saying no I can say from what
I've seen from the speeches and from the
news reports that's not true and um I
can only assume he's lying on purpose
for political power right because they
saw how effective this was when Paul
Ryan uh started talking about social
security and Medicare and you know he's
pushing granny off a hill he's going to
kill Granny and they saw the
effectiveness in that and haven't
haven't stopped even in my first
election the Democrat that I was running
against was saying that I was going
against these things I was like this
hasn't been on any of my talking points
this isn't part of any of my contract
with Colorado that I've laid out and
what I plan to do when I get to
Washington DC and so they're just
starting this rhetoric all over again
because they want to scare people they
understand the power of fear and that's
how they govern and I I won't govern out
of fear I won't be governed by fear and
they see this as a powerful tool to
scare people into to falling in line one
of the things uh that I've been talking
about for the past couple days
egg prices because I don't know if you
know if you follow I'm a big fan of
chickens because we have chicken sitting
we have chickens all over the place and
uh I it's somewhat of a joke when I talk
about hey everybody get out of the
Cities get some animals get chickens and
it's funny because it's meant to be
somewhat silly because I find chickens
to be entertaining but then we get this
egg crisis you better dance on them we
we have they have armor actually they
have the the big straps on their
shoulders because well it's because the
roosters can be a little rough you know
when they take what they want but uh but
no now we're dealing with it with an egg
and chicken shortage which has been
coming in and out actually and what I'm
hearing from a lot of the more liberal
people is that well no this is caused by
the avian flu which it doesn't explain
why people are smuggling eggs from
Mexico into the United States right
which is more indicative of a policy
problem that's not being taken care of
or fixed so what was that are we getting
somewhere nope nope but but in that
regard I guess uh my question for you is
what what do you think should be done
right now that would help lower the cost
of food maybe increase wages like what
are some economic ideas that you think
the Republicans could Implement I I mean
obviously we're working on the spending
there's been Reckless spending here in
Washington D.C
um you know and rightfully both parties
are are to cause or to blame for that
um but the past two years uh I it's just
been absolute out of control spending
whatever you want you get a stimulus
check and and we're we're increasing all
of all of these
um uh spending bills by trillions of
dollars we're given less than 24 hours
to actually read the bills before we
vote on them um so that's obviously a
big factor um so we're going to tackle
that debt ceiling debate um here in the
upcoming months but also American Energy
I mean let's get us energy independent
again Joe Biden surrendered that you
talk about surrender he surrendered our
American Energy on day one in his office
at the stroke of a pen and so let's
drill here responsibly let's have
American Energy uh and uh and and
produce that reliably and affordably
um for Americans I mean those those two
things right there coupled together
lower inflation and uh and help
Americans get out of this mess Biden
literally he campaigned on ending fossil
fuels yes he was on the debate stage
saying that he will work to end fossil
fuels in this country then he does the
State of the Union addresses not just
this one but the past one where he's
talking about how he's going to help but
he's not now in fact we just got uh new
emails released the Daily Mail reported
this Hunter Biden laptop emails showing
that Joe and Hunter were working on a
deal to sell natural gas from Louisiana
to China right now I think I think it
was after he was vice president before
he became president but I mean it's
clearly based on what he said and what
he's done as a private business person
in between his his uh public office
he seems to be more interested in
selling off our energy and shutting it
down yes absolutely uh well I mean even
emptying our strategic petroleum uh
petroleum reserves that was in the name
of a midterm election uh this was for
emergencies and he did it uh to win
political points with voters uh but no
he's absolutely shutting down American
Energy and even in the State of the
Union last night uh Joe Biden's like hey
look I get it
oil we got at least a decade left of it
like what the entire Republican party
just uh erupted and and laughed her at
him so he did campaign on canceling uh
fossil fuels and he did it on day one uh
on day one
um there was all of these executive
orders that came out moratoriums on um
leases on federal lands and ending
fracking in Colorado's Western Slope we
used to have 112 rigs drilling now we
have four our communities have been
regulated into poverty and it's really
unfortunate because we produce the
cleanest energy and Nobody Does it
Better Than American Energy producers
and he's shutting it all down you know
what I think is worrying with all of
this
Joe Biden can do all of these things he
can he can put a moratorium on uh oil
and gas leases on Federal Land he can
shut down Keystone Pipeline
regular people can't understand how that
leads to higher gas prices right because
it's a bit outside of the common
knowledge and I'm not trying to be
disrespectful to anybody who doesn't get
it but uh we've talked about on this
show when he shuts down Keystone we get
the talking points in the media that
this thing was never delivering oil in
the first place therefore it doesn't
matter on on this show we explain
speculation that if right now they're
telling you in the next five years we
will not be able to meet demand because
Transportation will be unavailable that
means Supply will be constrained this
causes people to speculate the prices
are going to go up which causes the
immediate effect of them buying as much
as possible which drives prices up yes
so it's all interconnected and I wish it
was much much simpler than this but I
can put it simply when you've got
California Oregon Washington saying
where to ban gas cars yet their agenda
is clearly aligned with shutting down
fossil fuels because they're concerned
about climate change right look fine I
mean if they're concerned about this
stuff I get it I think you know there's
pollution pollution bad and all this
stuff but this idea that we get from the
more extreme elements of this movement
no notably Greta tunberg which is she
outright said we want to shut down
fossil fuels now we don't want to wait
like that would result in 60 million
dead around the world within like a day
or so absolutely you know fossil fuels
have lifted so many people out of
poverty uh and uh they do want it shut
down and even when California said you
know we're going to ban gas vehicles
well the very next week they said hey uh
please don't charge your electric
vehicles because our grid can't handle
it I mean that was the very next week
and so their policies do not work
they're they're not effective
um but they are effective in their
messaging and uh and they're they're
doing everything that they can to to
destroy it
um if they want to talk about climate
change well I I mean I have forestry
legislation
um that deals with that very issue and
look I'm not here to deny climate change
it's real it happens four times every
year I'll go on the record and say it
but if carbon emissions if that's if
that's your problem well then let's
manage our forests because one
catastrophic Wildfire emits more carbon
emissions in a few short days than every
vehicle call in my state of Colorado
running 24 7 for an entire year
no through on YouTube nothing nope nope
[Laughter]
it's not the carbon that's being
produced that's the problem it's the
carbon in the atmosphere that's the
problem and if we can pull it out of the
atmosphere which we can and turn it into
graphene and re-industrialize our
country I mean it's it's waiting for us
to take and it's going to become
competition for the carbon in the air
the Chinese CCP is going to start
attempting to strip it out faster than
we can so if we don't work together hi
everyone is it working
you can tell me good please you can hear
no I don't know
yeah it's just Proof of Life
well so you know look I I
I like the I I understand people are
concerned about carbon emissions and I
think there's like a rudimentary there's
there's something basic that people can
understand in the more people you have
the more energy you consume the more
waste products are produced the more
pollution you get and I think the
simplest the the best way it's been
explained by a lot of conservatives is
we must be good stewards of the Earth
right but I'm sorry as as much as you
know I'll I'll back up I saw it for
Greenpeace briefly I worked for an
organization called environment America
I actually went around telling people
like hey we got to be good stewards of
the earth we got to protect the forest
we got to clean this stuff up and then I
got really confused when I'd hear
stories about politicians buying
beachfront property while telling me
that they're going to be swept up in the
oceans and so my thought was either they
don't care about what happens to the
rest what what happens to this planet in
20 or 30 years if they're coming out and
saying we're gonna work these it's gonna
be wiped out in 20 years but then they
buy the property they clearly don't care
right or they're just lying right
everybody looks like we're back on no
you're not
what
let's make sure you're early on first
and also did you guys hear me talking
about carbon sequestration because
because darn it that was good stuff
no audio for me in so so we have a we
have an audio meter it's showing like
Ian you're not coming in yeah so we can
hear you in the headphones but no one
can hear you on the show so I don't know
um you can maybe bring the bring the
chair over here and then I'll just swing
the mic around to you
you know
Brian says no yeah well maybe some
people are picking up the feedback from
the other mics yeah like you might be
able to hear something faint in the
background well I don't know see if I
don't know man look we threw this
together in a couple hours it is what it
is so let's just uh we'll just keep
talking I suppose you know I don't know
if anyone you pull want to pull up a
chair or something
okay Ian's gonna try and see what he can
figure out with this stuff but yeah so
look uh I grew up in the city I grew up
in Chicago I grew up surrounded by
liberals I grew up surrounded by
democrats and they and and it all makes
sense to me when you hear stories about
dead zones in uh in the Gulf of Mexico
where life can't exist when you hear
about the mercury levels in our fish I'm
like hey these things sound really
really bad I would like to uh have you
know ecological balance I'd like to
clean up pollution I don't like the idea
of big garbage dumps I'm concerned about
the pollution produced by big cities
and then I just don't trust them right
when you know Obama so we actually did
this we pulled up the I think it was
what is it the um NOAA or the uh what's
the ipcc the climate change panel we
looked at their projections for Obama's
property at Martha's Vineyard right it
will be underwater right so according to
their predictions yeah they're they're
and that that wasn't even their worst
case predictions there it was like
moderate predictions of sea level rise
puts half his property underwater in 10
or 20 years right and I'm just kind of
like well does he really care about this
because if he's what what he and all the
rest of them are saying is true does he
not care that he's spending 10 million
dollars on property they'll be worthless
soon right that's why I can't trust it
right absolutely uh you know and I I was
wondering why AOC got so worked up over
ilhan Omar not being able to serve on on
a certain committee when the world's
gonna end in six years anyway yeah they
they tend to keep saying this and then
people just end up not wanting to
believe it which is on did you guys
figure it out
nope turned it off and I'm still not
working unplug it plug it back in
no but uh but we can continue
so anyway
are you guys friends
I'll I'll relay that uh are you friends
no club members no I pretty much have to
take the stairs now because I'm not
allowed in elevators with her wait what
really no
well so let's actually yeah that's an
interesting question look I wanna uh
talk about the the the the Twitter stuff
too but let me let me ask you about just
the the general feel in Congress what we
see with AOC especially today in the
Twitter hearings is outrage right over
January 6 outrage over Republicans yes
what's what what's it like between you
know the freedom caucus or or just you
personally and Squad members
I mean I don't have a relationship with
them uh you know there there were some
things that obviously um you know we
kind of
we kind of had some of the issues when
we were in the minority because they
were trying to kick against their party
and we were all for that
um but uh I I don't have that
relationship and you know it's really
hard and um to to take anything these
guys say seriously because everything
out of their mouth starts with mega
Republicans did this in January 6 and
insurrectionists and you know all of
this rhetoric instead of actually just
talking policy and talking Solutions
let's have a conversation they were
saying that today's Twitter file
hearings
um regarding the hunter Biden laptop
that was suppressed by Twitter by these
Twitter uh Executives uh that was a
waste of time and that we need to move
on how is defending free speech and
holding people to account a waste of
anyone's time would that we are the
oversight and accountability committee
we are there to have congressional
oversight we uh where we believe that
there was collusion between the federal
government and with Twitter with big
Tech and so we were having congressional
oversight into what actually happened
was there collusion with the federal
government and the and these companies
and and then I expect accountability to
come out of this as well
yeah I think it's because it benefits
their party
this is this is the strangest thing when
when AOC gets elected when she defeats
uh I think was Crowley back in 2018. he
was like the fourth highest ranking
Democrat at the time she wins I actually
cheered for I said good Screw The
Establishment these people have been in
power they've not done anything if some
young upstart comes in and pushes him
out let's see it but now it seems like
he's just saying whatever the
establishment wants her to say she's
completely in line she's voting on the
on the same War stuff right yes she's
saying oh the hunter Biden laptop stuff
no issue we shouldn't talk about it she
said it was it was half true why does
why is she I I guess you know my I'll
I'll put it this way I when we walked
into these office I saw you on on the
live TV talking about illegal immigrants
voting in DC and I thought to myself how
did something like that become partisan
right how is it that there are issues
that are so obvious a big Corporation a
multinational corporation with
billionaire foreign investors at the
time Elon Musk now has taken over and we
can make an argument about that but at
the time you had foreign investors and
foreign interests involved in a multi
National Corporation that was
suppressing the speech of not just
conservatives though mostly
conservatives but even some anti-war
leftists got caught up in this yet they
are completely like no no no who cares
who cares everybody nothing to see here
and I'm just confused as to how that's a
left or right issue I mean I get it it
benefits their party right and the
narrative that they've been pushing as
well I mean look they are for uh wide
open borders uh that's why they've done
nothing to secure our Southern border
that's why we're seeing nearly 5 million
people come into our country illegally
that we know of that that doesn't even
count the unknown godaways that we have
no idea who they are what they're
bringing into our country uh and so this
is a part of their party platform at
this point and so of course they want
them to vote they're inviting them in
they're allowing them to come in and
they're promising them a free health
care free uh free college a free free
education uh free lawyers free cell
phones any anything else you want and
they're really treating our
um our country to like an Oprah Winfrey
Show and now they're saying you get a
vote too uh and this should not be a
partisan issue this should be something
that we all unite and say no only
American citizens can vote in United
States elections you know what I find uh
I definitely want to go back to the the
immigration thing too but in terms of
like the Twitter stuff we've we've
invited often many people on this show
who are more left-leaning and only a
very very small number of them actually
come on but there's one thing that's
consistent every time they do they don't
know what they're talking about and I
mean that with all due respect I think
the the most well-read individual we've
had on the show is vosh I'm not sure if
you're familiar with him he's a YouTuber
he's a socialist guy and there's a lot
he didn't know but there was a lot he
didn't know and I can respect that I
just think he's wrong on you know on his
opinions socialism Etc but we had people
on who I asked them about Ukraine I
asked them about uh issues at the border
and they literally don't know what's
going on you ask them Remember When
Donald Trump said coyotes are coming
across the borders yes yes I do remember
that the media made fun of them because
they didn't they thought he was talking
about animals carrying babies yes no how
do you how do you debate someone in
Congress how do you pass a bill when you
say hey coyotes are bad and they go who
animals right because most of this is a
facade you have a 20 25 year old
staffers give you your talking points
you go down you read them at the mic and
and then you leave when you're done and
you vote the way your party tells you
how how you're wrecked a lot of members
don't talk about the legislation that
they're voting on before they vote on it
they go down there and say is this a yes
or no how's the party voting and and
really it's just a numbers game you have
the majority you get it passed and now I
do think that the way that we have
changed the way Congress operates that
that did kind of kind of help that a
little bit and and members have to pay
attention to what they're doing and even
the party has to pay attention to what
we are wanting because they've seen that
any five members at any time can take
down a bill can take down a rule and so
they have to pay attention more and have
more communication and dialogue are you
a Ron Paul fan
uh yeah yeah I'm I I'm curious about
that I feel like
you know when I was younger
and I started learning about I started
learning more about Congress and
politics Ron Paul was getting very very
popular you know end of the 2000s and
it's because he's a very libertarian guy
he talks about personal responsibility
and things like that and that that said
a lot to me my the point I made at the
time was look you know I may not agree
with him on some of his more
conservative viewpoints and religious
viewpoints but then he comes and says
yeah but I'll leave you alone right I'm
like okay you know yes just take
government off my back well yeah and
obviously Rand Paul's doing a great job
and then Thomas Massey I mean he came to
Congress and he picked up a lot of Ron
Paul's bills
um when he came here um uh so he he's
someone who said this guy's doing it
right I want to introduce a legislation
he was introducing and I mean Thomas
Massey I mean he's more libertarian
leaning
um than most members here and so he's a
wonderful Ally to have he and I co-chair
the Second Amendment caucus together
um but you know he he wants to limit the
federal government limit spending and uh
and and make sure Americans are still
free so let's go back we'll go back to
the Twitter stuff because I don't want
to go the reason I brought up Ron Paul
was because the beginning of this big
social media push we saw that Ron Paul
Revolution Love Revolution thing and I
kind of feel like
many members of Congress today that we
like Freedom caucus types or the the
people who stood up against the
establishment who you know refused to
vote for Kevin McCarthy we had a good
laugh about that it seems like
a lot of this may have been inspired by
that time by that you know Ron Paul
Revolution so it got me thinking about
that with social media today and the
manipulation of big Tech and the
censorship of ideas when we have people
on the show and they don't know what's
what's going on what we're talking about
right like this is the problem AOC goes
up before uh these Executives and
outright says this was a 20 what did you
call it a 24-hour mistake or something
on Twitter that doesn't matter and we're
wasting public resources
she said that Libs of tick tock spread
lies about the Boston Children's
Hospital providing hysterectomies
however on their own website there was a
video or I should say this there's a
video of a woman from the Boston
Children's Hospital explaining what a
hysterectomy is and they they say on
their website that uh or it's been
reportedly as people have been sharing
they uh provided hysterectomies to
adolescents now AOC doesn't know that or
she's lying uh I guess I'll ask you do
you think she's lying or do you think
she doesn't know I think she's saying
what she was told to say
I mean it's as simple as that so a
little bit of both whether that yeah
whether it's an outright lie or doesn't
want to believe the truth doesn't want
to hear something else this is what she
has heard and that is what she is
regurgitating
man uh I'm coming into bat again can you
hear me Chad nope it's okay you're not
coming through you're you're just yep or
you can pull the chair up and we can
swing the mic over because we're gonna
have two people at a time uh that's the
plan so maybe so there's but yeah so
there's no audio coming through when you
talk but uh I guess we'll just keep
going unless you want to pull up a chair
so uh what I can hear Ian talking but I
can see on this on the monitor they are
not going into YouTube the the the sound
board is not delivering their
microphones to the computer so one
option is to you uh I I know exactly
what the problem is but there's no way
to fix it in real time it is it's it's
an issue
it's an issue we've dealt with with new
computers before where you have to
change a stereo mono setting or
something like this because there's two
channels but the board is
the board is only delivering one of its
channels to the computer which is why
we're not getting audio from the other
other microphones so it is what it is I
don't think I'll be able to fix it so
we'll just you know we'll hang out we'll
do what we can Ian we can we can have
you come and sit over here we'll throw
the microphone when you can but uh yeah
so so you know back to the the Twitter
stuff because I don't want to keep
wasting time talking about the fact that
our audio is not working it is what it
is uh
it feels one thing that we've talked
about in the show is cultural Decay you
know the the dark Direction this country
has headed if we can't solve this but
the way I've described it is
if you if you have a uh a person who has
become hypoxic right that the low oxygen
in the brain they can't think straight
they will not be able to write
themselves to save themselves so that's
why when you're on an airplane they say
put on your own oxygen mask before the
person next to you if half of our
country is effectively hypoxic due to
bad information lies and fake news from
the media
so they're not thinking clearly but
they're still voting right how is this
country supposed to write itself when
one lobe has been you know starved of
oxygen yes that's why it is so important
for us to have these hearings and
investigations look we don't have
um all we we don't have the Senate we
don't have the white house but we do
have the house we have oversight
um capabilities so we can begin to
expose this truth expose the mainstream
media expose big Tech and what they have
been doing and how they have been lying
to the American people what they've been
covering up the lull
um that has been created by the
narrative that they push um by by the
rhetoric
um that they allow and then by by the
information that they suppress so that's
why we are doing this in oversight so we
can get that truth out to the American
people because so many people do just
listen to what they're told on TV on on
Twitter on social media and move on with
their day uh so it's so important for
people to know the truth was hidden from
you
on purpose
it's it's such a challenge every day to
try and convince someone they're being
lied to when they don't want to believe
they're being lied to you know so no one
wants to believe they're being lied to
yeah you want to think that you have
control of your life that that people
are trustworthy that uh you can engage
in these conversations and and watch the
news and it be accurate and factual and
go on with your day but I mean the truth
is if you if you watch the news you're
you're misinformed and if you don't
you're uninformed yup think about it
ideologically when I mention you know we
were talking about the non-citizens and
illegal immigrants voting it's not just
in DC I mean New York uh has been
various parts of New York have been
talking about it various parts of
California that to me shows there is a
I don't know it feels like the ship
we're on has hit the has hit the iceberg
the Titanic's hit the iceberg and it's
sinking you cannot have a country if
there's no borders it quite literally so
we've actually talked about the
definition of a country versus a nation
and
um I think a country requires Sovereign
borders that determine its jurisdiction
or something to that effect and a nation
is a reference to culture and people I
can't but look we've got people pouring
across the border to the point where uh
we we can't track them there's drug
smuggling there was just in Arizona on
the southern border a man shot an
illegal immigrant they charged him with
first degree murder so we have people
entering this country we have children
dying in the desert and in rivers
because it's an extremely dangerous trip
that's being encouraged effectively by
the Biden Administration and by various
ngos and then you have various parts of
the country saying let them vote and
they're expanding that to me it's like
hey what's going on man hey Byron Byron
Donald's we're missing a couple mics
here so I'm going to switch you spots
here in a second yeah we'll have you
jump over in a second but uh just to
wrap this this thought up before we yeah
Jump Around yep
that that that is the most immediate
leak that people are entering this
country illegally that Democrats are
calling for amnesty and for the right to
vote the end result of that is clear
there won't be a country correct and
that's what they want they want to
dismantle the system they want to create
chaos they want the system to fail
because they hate the system uh they
hate everything that our country was
founded on and they want to start over
so I mean this is no surprise uh that
they're wanting everything to be
different it's going to take eight to
ten years just to process the people who
came into our country illegally last
year what about the ones who are coming
into our country this year so all of
this is to com to create chaos to
dismantle the system and you know I
could call their policies a failure but
truly they're a success because this is
their intent yeah I think
um what's happening is the chaos that
they're trying to sow is essentially the
end of the liberal economic order after
World War II the British and the French
and the Americans were like 1949 we're
going to build this Empire to prevent
World War III so they did it now 70
years later that order is fading in the
New Order the world the liberal the New
World Order they call it is forming and
so in order to form this order they need
to create chaos to create the order out
of but I think there's a lot of useful
idiots that are being swept up and like
yeah toxic compassion we need to help
everybody
right like like I don't think Cortez I
don't get the vibe that she's like
orchestrating the downfall of America I
just think that she really cares about
people and like that can take you to
Dark Places if you I'm I'm not convinced
that um many of these Democrats actually
care about people and I know it's just
it's so cliche and tribalistic to say to
be sitting here with a Republican and
we're like oh Democrats are bad but man
it's just so weird to see someone like
AOC uh let's let's just be uh I I hate
being
um
I hate giving the benefit of the doubt
when she says the Boston Children's
Hospital lives of tick tock yoel Roth
says unfortunately Libs of tick tock is
still there and it's just like we we
have so much evidence let's let's let's
back away from that the hunter Biden
laptop yeah emails between Joe and
Hunter uh or I'm sorry not not between
Joan Hunter but emails between Hunter
Biden and his associates yeah emails to
uh Hunter Biden talking about setting up
a meeting with his dad Tony bobulinski
10 for the big guy private Equity deals
with China flying on Air Force two the
barisma deals I mean like I can cite so
many different stories right factually
proven that Joe Biden was doing these
things
and then when you talk to Democrats they
just either don't know don't care don't
believe you yes so to wrap it all
together
I'm I'm a bit pessimistic in can we
inform people and get the right vote
when we have two things going on one
these people you look at what Adam
Schiff did with the whole Russia gate
stuff with releasing private phone
records I mean some real dark and evil
stuff lies manipulations impeachments
When Donald Trump I believe stumbled
upon the Ukraine Gate scandal with Joe
Biden and the billion dollars and
following the prosecutor they
immediately blamed him for what Joe
Biden did and then impeached him and
impeached him for it for Joe Biden's
crime yeah exactly when you have that
and then you have Universal mail-in
ballots and ballot harvesting yeah I
gotta say I hate Colorado I hate right I
I'm I'm not so optimistic on I suppose
Republicans could launch a massive bout
harvesting campaign and if that's the
case then I'm not sure standing up and
educating people matters as much as just
knocking on their door and saying fill
it out right yes so I you know in
Colorado uh you know we're trying to get
those ballot harvesting uh campaigns in
in place we have to play by their game
it's legal in Colorado and we're not
doing it because we're not for it but
they're doing that and they're winning
the elections Colorado is turning Bluer
and Bluer we just lost our our
gubernatorial race by 20 points I I mean
this is absurd
um my my District's always been very
conservative and you know won by 546
votes uh so we have to start playing by
their games but you know I agree with
you I'm very much more pessimistic and I
don't think that they care about people
I think they care about power and
winning and and having control and one
of the thing things that they love the
most is controlling people that's very
obvious I can't relate to it man you
know I I can't relate to they just want
to win for the sake of winning I don't
know what they see in the future you
know I I think about traditional family
values as as somebody who's again from a
very liberal area where there's no
Republicans at all Chicago has been run
by democrats for 100 years or whatever
and I think about you know why do we
want traditional Family Values well we
want humans to succeed we want humans to
thrive we want humans to be happier we
want them to be better off we want to
find ways to make life better for
everybody but it seems like the policy
positions that they put forward do the
opposite you I I talk often about why it
is that in big cities typically they're
run by democrats typically crime is
through the roof right and then we we
literally watch throughout the past
several years crime getting worse in
these cities as they release more
criminals now you've got there was this
viral video out of New York where it
wasn't a viral video it was a viral
story where a meteorologist was
mercilessly beaten by teenagers and the
city said we will not criminally charge
these teenagers and I'm just like
are they trying to destroy or do they
just not care and they're extracting as
much as they can as the whole thing
crumbles I think it's all of it yeah I I
do they want to be in power they want to
run things their way and they know they
have to completely blow it up to to be
able to reconstruct whatever it is that
they're seeing their Utopia as but their
Utopia isn't going to work
we have a system that works it feels
like the mass the mass printing of money
is an attempt to destabilize the oh my
gosh I'll put that back on ladies and
gentlemen um but what's happening is
they're printing it into guys of modern
monetary Theory mmt because I think if
they print enough you got to reinvest it
in infrastructure uh the thing that
they're doing is they didn't put it they
didn't put in infrastructure they just
put in people's bank accounts so they're
actually building like factories that
will produce the product to make up for
the lost money yeah Ian Ian knocked the
the mic off they're gutting them I mean
uh you know look we got the money guy
here you want to talk about
Byron you want to jump in come come in
here Byron let's talk finances with them
look hey I'd like to see Tucker Carlson
try this huh Ian Ian busted the mic can
you get it
[Music]
Ian Ian was trying to grab the mic all
right all right Congressman Donalds
what's up how's it going man good to see
you you know what's your view of things
how's it going we just had those uh
hearings on big Tech and social media
yes
so look the first thing is I'm just
happy I made my colleagues Wall of Fame
over here you know Brett bobert we were
over here in Texas at the at the gun
range in Texas and so I was looking at
the wall of fame and I was like dang I
don't take enough pictures with Bo burn
I was like oh shoot I made the Wall of
Fame in the corner so I'm happy about
that
the wall of fame you show the people the
wall of fame show the people
all right so listen what I want to tell
everybody real quick is about the 50 cal
that I'm holding in my hand so here's
the funny story they brought the they
brought the rifle out and so they were
like give it to bobert and so I'm like
the rifle is bigger than her like what
is going on but she's holding it like a
boss Like A Champion she's holding a
thing and so I'm looking and I'm like
you know what I respect I respect her
for that and so she like looks at me and
she's got the smile she goes Byron take
the rifle
so I'm like all right so I grab it with
one arm
The Rifleman I got the rifle she's like
trying to see the rifle pilbert I got
the rifle don't worry about it so that
was a funny story from that day it was a
great event great time
you remember that event
it was a great event I couldn't even
tell you're holding it you're like
barely even got it what was the event oh
we were doing a fundraiser at um a gun
range in Dallas I think it was was it
CPAC in Dallas at the time yeah yeah it
was CPAC in Dallas and um really I
crashed the fundraiser I wasn't supposed
to be there
um I wasn't even a special guest I
literally just crashed it was Beth Van
Dyne uh Ronnie Jackson and bobert and I
got wind of it and I just said you know
what I'll show up so it was a good time
it was awesome time I try to be
supportive of my colleagues because this
business is a crazy it's a crazy
situation is this oh this mic's really
loud yeah we got we got a new mic and a
new mic stand so it'll be easier to talk
but uh yeah I mean that's cool it's cool
seeing people carrying guns I think we
got to repeal the NFA I think uh I mean
I'm I'm pretty I went from being like a
moderate gun control kind of guy we're
like well you know maybe we could have
something to a staunch like nope all
legal all of it all the time what do you
think oh I think that's right because
here's the deal so I grew up in Brooklyn
New York so I'm gonna get a full story I
grew up in Brooklyn New York where you
know gun ownership is taboo you know in
the Inner City
the problem is is that people have guns
and people die which is legit that's
just the way of life growing up in the
inner city and so the politicians and
the media feed this Narrative of oh my
gosh guns are evil so nobody can have
them the truth of the matter is is that
if law-abided citizens had the ability
to possess Firearms with mineral
restriction minimal restrictions no
restrictions what you would see is the
criminal element would understand you
know what I can't
act crazy because I'm not sure who's
carrying the vast majority of people
just want to live in harmony and peace
with one another they're not trying to
cause problems but when the criminal
element understands that the politicians
restrict gun ownership to the degree
where normal people feel is taboo and
it's the wrong thing to do it actually
empowers a criminal element it's it's
kind of sad because that's I just feel
like Common Sense obvious I've heard it
a million times throughout my life
that an arm Society is a polite Society
if people in the cities were armed and
criminals would be scared of them
because you have equal force to be used
against you but it doesn't seem to get
through to these gun control Advocates
and now we have Joe Biden coming out
with the what what was his slogan Let's
uh let's get the job done or was it
finish the job I don't really know what
he was talking about he was yelling too
much he was he was slurring a bit too
but he said let's finish the job ban
assault weapons right and they can't
even Define what it is so this goes back
to what I was just asking congresswoman
bobert right how do you affect change in
a positive direction with with through
logical lens to make things better if
your political opponents don't know what
they're talking about well the first
part is you know I always go back to
Gladiator I'm gonna date myself a little
bit you know I'm 44. that movie with
Russell what was it listen Gladiator was
that movie that's a good movie it was
that was that movie and you know the
advice Phoenix the advice to um you know
to Russell Crowe maximus in the movie
was you win the crowd you win your
freedom and so on a on a philosophical
level politics hasn't really changed
Politics the art of politics is really
about can you get enough people in the
body populace
in the in the population to be with you
if you can get enough of them to be with
you
then you can then you have the political
will to move the argument to move the
bill to move the policy but it if you'd
ever get the people to see your side and
be on your side you can't win your
freedom that's the way you can actually
in some respects break Washington loose
because for a long time you know as a
conservative the media is against you
you know that
Republicans largely have been terrible
at messaging we know that so it ends up
becoming people deciding to engage in
politics and policy of their own
volition of their own passions and the
nut I think that you know I guess the
new the new age myself bobert and others
Gates and others that we're trying to
crack is
is there the possibility to get
your average American
to look at our arguments and be like you
know what that Byron dude is right I
like what he's saying I think and that's
the pathway I think the internet helped
greatly but I also think there's a
there's an inverse reaction too because
you end up with these people one of the
examples of social media manipulation
I've brought up is that imagine you're
10 years old in 2008 right Facebook is
just coming into you know popularity and
prominence or it's getting bigger and
bigger and these companies like BuzzFeed
and hovenin post find out that you know
what kind of article gets the most
traffic
police brutality 100 so they start
making more and more and more of it
right now you're a little kid and you're
on Facebook and the only thing you see
every single day is more and more videos
of police brutality rap songs about I
don't know if you've ever you've seen
that rap song this is what happens when
you call the cops I mean I'm a hip-hop
kid so I even go back to NWA Ice Cube
Snoop you know that's how far I go back
yeah I'm A hip-hop kid I love hip-hop so
you're you're you're a little kid and
you're seeing this nothing but this for
10 years 10 years later you're 18 you're
ready to vote your whole world is shaped
around this idea that police are going
around mercilessly murdering people and
targeting black people and it's just an
extreme insane exaggeration built by
social media manipulation so as much as
the internet's empower the ability of
conservatives who tended to have a bad
mess bad messaging or were locked out
from the media you end up with people
who are living in a deranged State like
Trump derangement Syndrome from this
stuff like how do you reach these people
and
I mean how do you it feels like the
country's bifurcated the point where to
put it another way you've got the West
Coast wanted to ban gas vehicles you've
got some states banning child sex change
operations some states becoming
sanctuaries for child sex change
operations I don't see how you pull that
stuff together how do you bring these
cultures back together I mean look it's
very difficult but that's where programs
like yours come in you know I mean
bobert was like Hey Byron you got to
come in and do this podcast tonight I
said you know whose podcast are we doing
she's like let me tell you about them
it's great I said all right cool I'm in
I'm gonna do it cool you have to do
programming like this I think that
the way that our party has done
messaging is you deal with the
Washington Post the New York Times
MSNBC NBC CBS ABC they hate your guts
you know you're going to get a hard
interview when Fox came along 30 years
ago Fox was like a revelation for for
the conservative movement for the
Republican party just being out it was a
revelation right yeah but because young
people taking information on this thing
at warp speed because I got three kids
they look at their phones they don't
even watch TV anymore so I try to tell
my colleagues oh my gosh
don't get me wrong doing interviews is
cool
but there's a whole nother uh ecosystem
you have to penetrate
how do you do it do you do it through
reels do you do it with shorts do you do
it with responses to some narrative out
of media and it's not just doing it once
it's not just saying oh I went on and
there's no disrespect to Sean Hannity
love to do a good dude but it's not just
doing a Hannity Prime Time Hit it's are
you in a rapid fire response pushing
narratives pushing messages what's
actually happening being able to explain
the thing in 90 seconds like you you
don't have 20 minutes and don't get me
wrong like look I'm about as eloquent as
they come people love listening to me I
don't got 20 minutes I got 90 seconds to
get this thing right but think about
even in Congress uh yet what five
minutes to question Twitter right how do
you how do you get through a deep
conversation to break down the issues
that are negatively impacting this
country if they're like your five
minutes begins now good luck well that's
why I try to change the rules so what
I've been talking to the chairman and to
the speaker was we got to get out of
this mindset of every member is
recognized for five minutes that's
ridiculous
by the time you get warmed up the time
is over
and then the other thing is a lot of
members waste time because they're
trying to fill their time and then the
third piece is staff members write most
of the questions in most of these
speeches so you'll see the member like
this and they'll be reading a thing like
this and they'll never look at the
person sitting in the chair and their
eyes are down because they're reading it
you don't have an opportunity to engage
in a legitimate Dialogue on the issues
presented
so my my position has always been look
get rid of seniority recognition get rid
of the five minutes have the chairman
recognize members as they choose to be
recognized what you would have is a
dialogue between members a dialogue with
the witnesses then you can get into a
situation like that oh I don't have my
five minutes I got one question I threw
out a question ocasio-cortez does
whatever she does on the other side I
look at it like oh that's a bunch of BS
chairman let me in I come back fire back
that's how you get the dialogue moving
that's what Congress doesn't do right
because Congress is fixated on
doing your clip for a newsreel that
might show up in one of the network news
shows at night or maybe the New York
Times might report on it or the
Philadelphia Inquirer or whatever or the
LA Times we're in a different uh genre
in Media
and so you got to have that conflict in
a positive way to get the message out to
people to see what's really happening
what do you think about the the squad
how is your relationship with them so I
talked to some of them on the side you
know I just keep it professional
um again I grew up in the inner city so
for me
it's never personal until you mess with
like my personal safety or my family or
my money
you do that
now it's personal
everything else is business is that why
in Congress because people are getting
like basically bribed by you know
pharmaceutical companies they're whoever
they're they're what they call them
lobbyists that they actually feel like
you're threatening their money if you're
passing a bill that denies that's not
even it because the truth is about
lobbyists is they're going to write you
a check regardless well the lobbyist
really wants is access they want to be
able to be like look if I passed you a
five thousand dollar check if I call you
a staff or if I if I happen to have your
cell phone will you answer my call and
give me an opportunity to explain myself
lobbyists are counting votes which also
is what leadership in both Chambers is
doing they're counting votes that's all
they're doing I tell people at home all
the time look if you call my office just
you by yourself I'm not even gonna like
I don't even know that you called if a
hundred people called my office my chief
of staff knows and she's like hey Byron
uh we had 100 calls on this issue if a
thousand people call my whole office
knows what's going on and I definitely
know what's going on that's how this
works the lobbyists all they're doing is
trying to have an ability to have a
conversation with the member if you have
members who change their opinions just
because of what a lobbyist says you got
a weak member that person probably needs
to go home and not be an elected
official real talk right
but the issue is not just a lobbyist per
se when I talk about being able to talk
with members on the other side Squad
members
me and Jamal Bowman we talk football we
don't even talk politics we know we
don't agree on politics so we're talking
about the NFL we talk football and
because we talk football we have a an
ability to engage each other if there's
something popping up where a
conversation needs to be had
um with the squad members
for everybody who says oh Freedom caucus
members are always causing problems in
Republican leadership Squad members
cause problems in Democrat leadership
they do the same thing on the other side
but our politics are so different
that's why people think we're always at
odds with them they seem to be marching
more in lockstep with the rest of the
party these days though especially when
it comes to War I would argue that what
they've done on their side is they've
gotten their party till Marcia locks up
with them wow you know how many Democrat
members are afraid of being primaried by
Squad members or potential Squad members
a lot of them I kind of like that to be
honest but I'm just keeping it real you
know why Chuck Schumer Chuck Schumer was
acting you know was wilding out and
starting to say all these positions he
didn't want to be primaried by AOC
that's why I hope she doesn't and look
you know I love it me and Cortez I talk
to her every now and again but
Chuck Schumer I didn't want that smoke
I promise you that he didn't want that
action I gotta I gotta I gotta say about
AOC right one of the biggest issues I
have is she's talking about January 6
and she fabricated a story about what
happened so she says that she's in her
office and someone knocks on the door
and then she hides in the bathroom and
someone says where is she where is she
and all this stuff and
then you then you get the response from
the conservatives saying she wasn't even
in the Capitol Building then you get the
response to the media saying yeah but
they're all connected then I looked at
this and I was like her story took place
an hour before the capital was even
breached yeah why would she hide in the
bathroom thinking someone was coming for
her unless she knew in advance people
are going to break into the building or
her story is fake well I mean look she
you know she lives by the drama code of
politics you know it's like the other
thing where
she was at the protest in front of the
Supreme Court and she tried to fake like
she got arrested yeah she put her hand
inside she put her hands behind her back
and raised her hand I'm like come on sis
you ain't getting no cuffs on you
because if you did you could you know
it's stuff like that so she lives by the
drama of politics it is what it is but I
think that
what has happened in both parties
is that you've had the reflection of
Voters
who were tired of establishment politics
they're tired of being given a false
narrative or a half a narrative that
isn't really real that because there's
some deal cut up here in Capitol Hill
that the people don't know about they're
cut out of the process and so what we
call the squad on the other side is
really the the culmination of the Occupy
Movement a decade ago what you call
Freedom caucus members on our side is
really the Fulfillment of the Tea Party
wave 10 years ago
because voters on both sides of the
political Spectrum have had enough of
this business business as usual in
Washington D.C that's actually a good
thing so what's happened in the Democrat
Caucus is the reason why it appears that
the squad just kind of goes along
they've actually moved their caucus
on a myriad of issues bruh they're out
here talking about how it's cool to dran
transgender kids
Joe Biden was that was not his position
a decade ago I promise you that but the
reason why he's got to be cool with that
now is because that is where the base of
his party has gone in part because of
members like the squad and activists in
the Democrat base
I feel like what's happened I feel like
that is representation of uh
analogous to fire a chaotic destructive
force that is spreading I I think that
if you actually you know what I don't
think this I know this if you go to your
average American and you show them the
book genderqueer for instance you've
heard about this book I've heard about
it and it's got graphic images in it
it's a pretty messed up book if you read
the whole thing too and it's it's sad
it's it's this woman was traumatized but
when I when I tell regular people this
and and we we live and work about a half
an hour away from where that big Loudoun
County fight was happening with these
schools they say that's not true I say
here is a physical copy of the book open
it up they look at it and they say this
had to have been one school and so what
you end up with is uh people like the
squad people in their activist base
which I believe represents a very small
percentage of this country who are
advocating for extremist policies either
open borders abolishing Private health
care child sex change operations things
like that and when you talk to regular
Americans they don't believe it's
actually happening right they don't I
don't they actually want to they
actually want to abolish Private health
care yes and not just establish a public
option they uh the public option was a
pathway to Universal Health Care always
was right so one of the weird things
when Scott Brown got elected in
Massachusetts the reason why Nancy
Pelosi just pushed for uh Obamacare the
Affordable Care Act as was is because
she understood that if they did the push
for a public option it would have
completely blown up the bill and there
would be no Obamacare so her position
was let's just get the thing we got
right now because we can't send it back
to the Senate because we don't have 60
votes anymore we got 59 and if it comes
back this way it's done and that's what
happened so they're still mad because
they thought the game plan was public
option because public option would have
eviscerated private insurance because
everybody would have just dumped people
into the public option that's what they
wanted because but it didn't happen
because Scott Brown got elected that's
that's those are facts Bernie Sanders
campaigned during the during the 2020
election uh primaries not on creating a
private and public multi-faceted system
but outright abolishing all Private
health care which has never it's not
even like all the countries they tout in
Europe they have both they have both
yeah so I mean even my advocacy I've
been like you know if a kid gets the flu
I think it would be great if he could go
to the doctor and get Tamiflu if you
broke your arm you could go in and get
it taken care of you don't got to worry
about going bankrupt I think a lot of
Americans worry about that stuff and
then if you get something like Advanced
lymphoma which requires expensive bills
you know a certain amount of it is
covered but there's limitations to what
we can provide so I'm not fully on board
with we can cure every disease for every
single person and I'm in the Middle
where it's like it'd be nice if people
had some basic level of coverage but
what what's being proposed by the
progressives is one of the most extreme
positions in the world right I I
understand socialized emergency care if
someone falls down and breaks their arm
and they are poor you you help that
person but socialize chronic care when
which we basically have we have that and
that's cool because you want to save a
life saved life but when people eat
themselves into sickness and then I
expected the taxpayer to cover their
their injections of random Pfizer drugs
I'm not into it I don't want to pay for
people to eat sickness like sugar is
horrible for your body if you overdose
on that stuff well I like Snickers man
hold on man I like Snickers don't do
that like but I know your point I I see
your point I get your point I think the
key thing is is that you know the issue
with the Democrats is
it's never good enough
they constantly are pushing for the next
wave because what they fully ultimately
want is
complete control of the industry that's
what they want they'll never say that in
campaigns they'll never say that in
speeches but when you ask them well when
is enough enough they'll be like like
Joe Biden said the other day let's
finish the job well finish what job bro
you just spent five trillion dollars we
don't have we're at the debt ceiling now
you created a labor shortage in our
economy like when you pay people to stay
home what you do is create a labor
shortage what do I mean by that number
one you don't have to go work 40 hours
because there's money coming in from
somewhere else but you still have the
same amount of money to buy products
so people aren't working to the level
necessary to create all the products at
a certain cost but everybody's got money
to buy it
well what does that mean heavy demand
limited Supply means the prices go up
that's what's happened in the economy
Joe Biden did that if you had the
inflation reduction act which was like
one of the biggest misnomers in American
history that thing doesn't do anything
for inflation it was the green new
deal's little sister that's what it was
that was in that bill the inflation the
infrastructure bill was a Prelude to
build back better they just couldn't get
the votes because he wanted to spend too
much money if Joe manchin and Christian
Cinema were like yeah we're cool
spending another four trillion dollars
bill back better would have been law
facts that's the deal
so where we're at right now
you got to understand a couple things
one you cannot just spend money
recklessly the laws of Economics don't
change I don't care who you are I don't
care how well you speak I don't care how
cool you are I don't care what your fit
looks like you cannot spend money
unilaterally the laws that economics
don't change it hits everybody don't
believe me ask the Weimar Republic
so people people uh Super Chat us the
other day when he said let's finish the
job right we had a great Super Chat
sorry I forget I can't remember the name
of the individual who chatted us but he
said he's he's referring to jamming the
knife in the back of the of the Gasping
corpse of the economy he's saying let's
finish it off and to those that know his
policies have resulted in damage chaos
inflation Etc it sounds like he's saying
let's make it worse like I'm not tin
foil hat guy that's not me like you know
I'm a city kid man I just I deal in
common sense my grandmother God Rest her
soul was from Jamaica she will always be
like Byron yeah if I have common sense
boy you must think right that was her I
deal in common sense but when you look
at the policy outcomes of where they
want to take us that's only because the
only way you can fundamentally make
changes in our economy which is the best
by far the best in the history of the
world is you have to make it so hard
to earn money you have to make it so
difficult to keep wealth
that there has to be some fix from
Washington D.C and the fix is only more
control up here where people who frankly
with all due respect to my colleagues
they don't have the intellect to manage
your life they don't have it I know what
one thing that they've done we got a
bunch of new people coming in is that is
that who that is a lot of the um when
they printed all this money they're
telling American people that trust us
modern monetary Theory but what's great
what the trick is is they're not
investing the money in infrastructure
programs production and things that's
monetary theory is that you put you
print 10 trillion dollars you put it
into stat factories so that you start
producing Goods that are worth more than
the 10 trillion they're not producing
the things they're just putting it in
bank accounts look let me be let me keep
it real simple about modern monetary for
every one of your listeners has got a
little brother or little sister
let them just spend whatever they want
regardless of how much money is in the
family's bank account How's that gonna
work
it's an unmitigated disaster and mom's
gonna be mad somebody's getting a
spanking I still believe in spanking I
got kids I spank my kids it's whatever
you know social media can get mad at me
but it is what it is somebody's in
trouble
you cannot just spend money
without any controls on what comes in
nobody can do that if you borrow money
incessantly you create the situation
where republics have fallen that's
what's happened to too many republics in
the history of the world so when you
have conservatives like myself who say
look control spending make sure you're
doing it the right way when you do that
you create the environment for economies
to thrive for people to grow Etc real
quick because I'm gonna do the quick
segue because he usually segues for me I
get the opportunity to segue from him
ladies and gentlemen man sitting down in
the room right now
he is the Forerunner of what it means to
bring the diesel to question people this
is the guy you see with no jacket on but
a tie and a dress shirt he is the guy
that myself bobert and so many of us
have watched on TV and in committee
hearings grilling the Democrats day
after day after day this is one of the
forerunners of the conservative movement
in our country my good friend The
Honorable from Ohio Jim Jordan Byron
thank you Tim good to be with you yeah
how's it going man I'm doing fine
Byron's doing the interview here now
he's dead Oh that's oh listen I've been
down there I've been down to Naples and
talked to all his Republican buddies I
was gonna start though
with what is it called chicken City yeah
so my wife she she literally built we
have eight Acres out in the country
around her family's Farm she built her I
call it the Taj Mahal she built her own
chicken coop from scratch she did it all
and now we have the security camera
stuff up but she can watch her chickens
via security cameras so we got we got
great eggs and all but I understand you
guys are this is this is your thing too
so this is amazing yeah we have uh
chicken City we've got I think 30 or so
chickens we've got a camera you can
watch them all day there's be a couple
but now it's just one watching them all
do their chicken stuff yeah chickens are
hilarious yeah so she's had to save uh
come out yelling to get the fox away
because sweet you know she had started
with what nine and she's down to five
but we still get plenty of eggs I don't
know if you do that and they probably do
that in Naples
I go to the supermarket and get the eggs
yeah I appreciate ours are cheaper ours
are cheaper right now you know I'm gonna
come by I'm gonna come by the cheaper
yeah because you know I got sons and
they eat like eggs all the time because
they're all lifting weights and whatnot
and I'm out on that training they're
training all the time real quick I want
to ask you this one question and then
I'm gonna turn it over because I'm not
an interviewer I I answered too many
questions these days
my question for you
and I've never asked you this question
what what was the thing what was the aha
moment that made you realize that
conservatism was the path forward to for
the country
um I mean I was raising the conservative
family although my dad was a Democrat he
was a union worker for General Motors
and and like a lot of Americans in 1980
decided enough of this Democrat stuff
he's gonna he's gonna vote for the
Reagan guy
um but raising a conservative kind of
Christian home and but for me it's
probably Athletics you know um the the
idea in America is you know you you set
a goal you work hard and you you try to
accomplish things and that seemed to fit
with conservatism and my background's a
sport of wrestling one to play football
but I'm five seven and a half on a good
day so I had to wrestle
um but yeah it's probably wrestling
because it's all about competition I
think it's one of the problems in the
country today is
people you don't have people competing
and frankly I don't think you have
enough people just involved in being
tough no one gets in a fighting school
anymore you know enough kids playing
football or wrestling I think that's a
problem so
probably probably came from my my
background in the sport of wrestling
because I started when I was in third
grade and did it for the for the longest
time did you want to be a professional
wrestler Jim no there's no real
professional wrestling in amateur
wrestling you know I wanted to be a
statement WWE Champion no that's for
that's right that's for big guys like
you Byron that's right that's where guys
like you so all right time I wrote side
point and I'm gonna give up the headset
in the microphone so I went to a WWE
event oh golly in my district right yeah
because I like I actually like pro
wrestling yeah it's a thing for me I
like the Showmanship and all like it's
fun it's interesting so I go in the
locker room right they gave me like the
treatment they're like we're gonna bring
superstars in to meet with you I was
like okay cool you know the thing I
realized I'm bigger than most of the
dudes on the roster I got pictures with
Big E who was a WWE champion at the time
before he broke his neck because
somebody did a suplex and they messed
them up hopefully you know shout out to
Biggie hopefully he comes back
but I took a picture with the Money in
the Bank briefcase I got a picture and
I'm like three interest taller and I'm
like thicker than him and I'm like oh I
could do this yeah the only Pro you know
WWE people I know are the ones who are
in real wrestling uh Gable Stevenson was
three-time NCAA Champion right and uh
Olympic champ and now he's winning WWE
and doing fine and uh he's the guy who's
275 he went he wins the Olympics
um and 275 six foot whatever runs does a
round off into a full back layout and
I'm like 265 can do that means he's an
athlete so they are athletes but it's
you know it's It's Entertainment okay
that's the end of my WWE group because
I'm 275 and trust me I ain't doing that
no more so we're done all right sorry
Vince can't sign me let's talk with uh
with Congress Congressman Jordan about
Twitter do you want to hop over here and
grab the mic from Byron and then I just
want to add to that man you mentioned
wrestling and competition I grew up
skateboarding and skateboarding it's a
it's a very individualist
individualistic sport where you can't
cheat if you if you want to succeed at
the trick you have to commit to it and
if you don't do it that's it you didn't
do it it's for you not anybody else well
said so there's a lot of risk taking
there's a lot of overcoming fears and
real life lessons that come with it when
you're first standing on top of a a mini
ramp or a half pipe looking down about
to drop in it's terrifying I can imagine
but you can't fake it yeah you can't
pretend so let's let's talk about
Twitter because I mean this is this is
the the Twitter files it's a big deal
because
is the same way when you step out there
on the mat it's just you know you God
and your opponent and you know you win
you win you lose you lose and there's no
one to blame no one to it just that's
the way it is and it uh sort of teaches
you to deal with things just like you
had when you're standing on top and
going down into the with the
skateboarding what they call the half
Piper the half pipe quarter pipe various
sizes you know you're competing against
yourself yep if if you want to get that
good feeling of accomplishment
you can you can't lie to yourself you
know you didn't do it right yeah right
so I think that you know that that
instilled in me a lot of uh ideas of
personal responsibility individualism
Etc and I think you know getting getting
into skateboarding as a sport when I was
younger and then having the ability to
overcome and accomplish yourself you
know your goals in yourself with no one
in the way I think probably led me to be
more independent and individualist but I
do think physical activity and
competition is is important so you were
mentioning I'm a lot older than you but
when I grew up you you you played you
competed every day and I went to a
little local country public school every
you competed in the classroom you learn
on your multiplication tables you did
this thing you called around the world
you had to try to say that faster than
the person you Stood Beside and it was a
competition you kept moving it's like is
that the math thing yeah yeah we used to
do that too yeah that's good I don't
know if they've been a lot of kids that
do that in school today on the
playground we played kickball we played
football we played the game they can't
even say the name you throw the ball up
someone catches it you run away everyone
tackles him and you got the fight every
every couple weeks you get in the fight
with somebody it was all good
that's a life on the playground and you
didn't it wasn't a garage you just got
in a fight because you know he out safe
out safe and kickball no no we're gonna
get into fight and everything's fine but
I think we're losing some of that and I
I don't know that that's good yeah well
let's talk about censorship manipulation
I was uh talking with congresswoman
bobert and uh I gotta say I'm a bit
pessimistic because on this show for
instance we've had on only a few guests
who are more liberal leaning and we
invite many on but many just don't want
to do it the only ones who do either are
up and coming and looking for an
opportunity which you know we're trying
to
we do want to have some of these
individuals I don't want to limit
someone's ability to speak because
they're not famous or anything like that
but we're trying to engage in debates
with people who are influencing the
debate itself but they don't want to and
often what we find is people like Squad
members either are intentionally lying
or don't know what they're talking about
an example I'll give is when AOC today
said uh during the Twitter uh hearings
that Boston's Children Hospital was lied
about by Libs of tick tock claimed that
they were giving hysterectomies to
children but they actually list on their
website reportedly that they that they
offered hysterectomies to adolescents if
we want to be specific and there was
even a video where they described gender
affirming hysterectomies at a children's
hospital so either she knows what she's
saying is not true or she genuinely
believes incorrect things yeah if big
Tech is censoring conversations and even
us right now on this show are subject to
those restrictions how can we advance
the country in a positive direction come
to real solutions make people's lives
better if we can't even discuss the
problems no that that's the problem and
I think you've hit on the sort of the
key thing here the left today doesn't
embrace the First Amendment and that is
literally something that has changed in
my judgment in the last 10 to 15 years
it used to be the left with you know get
your best hold make your best argument
full Embrace of the First Amendment your
right to speak and let's let's let's
have the debate and see see who wins and
then we move on to the next issue that's
the way it used to be but not today
today the left says if you don't agree
with me you're not allowed to talk and
if you try we're going to call you
racist we're going to call you fascists
we're going to call you names we're
going to try to cancel you and I've said
this on the house floor when we were
talking about the whole cancel culture
uh culture phenomena I said don't think
that they won't come for you it's not
just to come after conservatives or
Republicans or libertarian they're going
to come for everybody and that very week
if I remember right that very week is
the week they said the Dianne Feinstein
Elementary School in San Francisco will
no longer be named after Senator
Feinstein she wasn't good enough liberal
icon not good enough because of
something she said 30 40 years ago that
is the problem and and look I got
liberal friend Dennis kucinich is a
friend of mine and you know he's way
over here and he thinks Jordan's way
over here but we're friends and he
believes in the First Amendment that's
the problem today is if you don't if you
don't go along with the left they try to
cancel you and their appetite I think
knows no bounds knows no end and they
will come for everyone that's why we got
to push back and we got to push back on
big Tech so that we have that Public
Square that Forum that Forum that is now
the Public Square are you winning
I think we're making some progress
finally and of course the biggest win
was Elon Musk Buy on Twitter and showing
us what was going on as my my good
friend Thomas Massey said he bought a
crime scene cost him billions of dollars
but he bought a crime scene
um and uh laying out what happened there
that first they had their written
policies that they enforced selectively
and then the closer they got to the
election the more they enforced them
selectively and then when their policies
weren't good enough they just had an ad
hoc way of like we're going to do
whatever we want to do and censor
whoever we want to censor do you think
the Twitter Executives lied today in
these hearings I think they didn't tell
us everything because you know one of
the things I just one question I'm just
talking with Lauren when she asked about
the hearing today too and I said uh the
one question sort of stuck on me I asked
because I looked at you know Baker's
testimony Jim Baker who was deputy chief
counsel and before that he was Chief
counsel of the FBI and um on the top of
the second page of his thing he says
that he he didn't improperly suppress
any information that would be good for
the public dialogue well if you didn't
improperly suppress then you believe you
properly suppressed something what was
it and when did it happen and he
wouldn't he wouldn't answer it and he he
had behind a privilege
um but I I want to know if that's right
around the time that the Twitter files
when musk bought Twitter and they're
doing the Twitter files and they find
out those are being filtered through Jim
Baker was he suppressing information
then I don't know so that was one of the
takeaways I had I wonder if there is
potentially an FTC violation with
Twitter in that before Elon Musk took
over and even now it there was this uh
before Elon Musk when you're on your
Twitter feed there's little stars in the
top right corner you click it it says
switch between your home feed which is
algorithmic and the latest tweets which
means that a user like me or any other
person who signs up if we select latest
tweets we expect to see the posts from
individuals we follow in Reverse
chronological order right but Twitter
was manipulating that feed while
advertising falsely what they were
delivering to people yeah so we asked
about that today so we asked um
great point we ask okay so when someone
gets their account suspended or get
suspended from it or their tweets being
you know taken down they there's a
notice of that but if they're doing what
they call other visibility filtering
like blacklisting someone stopping them
from trending they don't know that and
it's happening and I ask them like is is
are you doing that on specific accounts
is it driven by certain key words that
that that that enforce that how is that
done and they didn't really seem that at
least I didn't figure out how they how
they were answering that but the fact
that they were doing that and people
didn't know then I said did that happen
to any government officials or elected
officials and he said he didn't know but
he thought it did so this is this is
Joel Roth uh who we asked this question
to so again that's something and the the
examples and the Twitter files are
bongino and uh and Charlie Kirk that
that that happened to them and they
didn't know probably happened to you and
you oh yeah you know about it there
there are these apps you can use where
you enter your name and it'll tell you
the various filters that exist but even
Dave Rubin just mentioned Elon Musk just
showed him new ones they discovered new
filters but but I guess you know what
I'm thinking is
we often focus on the censorship aspect
which I think culturally and morally
those of us who care about real debate
and and logic and policy are shocked by
but I'm also curious how can Twitter as
a massive Corp company with 300 million
plus users lie about the product they're
delivering how can a corporation in
America say I'm gonna imagine this
imagine if a company said you come to me
here's a contract you get a gallon of
whole milk then they give you a gallon
of two percent yeah that sounds like
they're they're they're falsely
advertising what they're delivering if
Twitter says the reverse chronological
feed delivers you reverse chronological
posts but then they're using Shadow ban
algorithms and we know they are they're
lying to their customers as the product
being delivered how is that legal how is
that allowed yeah so one of the
questions asked too that you made me
think of this too I asked this question
um and I I didn't fully understand but
but I asked if they were hard coding
into any specific accounts to censor
them so they're like targeting that
specific user uh and it was interesting
how Joel Roth kind of I want to go back
and look at the transcript to see
exactly how he said it because he really
didn't to that square
um that either I agree one of the things
we want to do with with legislation that
we're we're planning on doing with
Energy and Commerce Committee
is anything they do to your account they
have to tell you there has to be real
transparency there has to be a time
frame there has to be a due process so
that you can correct it figure out what
it is to have the debate and correct
within a specified amount of time and
then if they don't then you should have
some kind of cause of action because
they're violating a contract that they
have with you their user their customer
and the scary thing about what we really
learned I think from the Twitter files
too is all the things they're doing
Twitter but why in the world is the FBI
coming in and telling Twitter hey these
accounts have problems they violate your
terms up to what of service Twitter like
well what's the government telling
Twitter these accounts violate Twitter's
terms of service what you got to be
kidding me and it wasn't because they
were concerned about you know you be in
Shadow band or anything else it was
because they wanted those accounts taken
down that to me is the scariest part of
all which is is come out in the Twitter
policy do you think that those
Revelations that uh Twitter and Facebook
had portals for government agencies to
flag content do you think that was
partisan that that the the yeah to help
Democrats I do because you know the way
I did it my my first round of question
Dave is I just I asked you know was the
hunter Biden's laptop story did the
government tell you it was fake no did
the government tell you it was hacked no
um and then I said and did it violate
your terms of service and he said no it
didn't but you took it down anyway why'd
you take it down I think they took it
down because
for months they've been meeting with uh
excuse me they've been meeting with
Twitter they had uh asked Twitter if
they wanted security clearances in 30
days prior to the election they'd send
them all kinds of emails heading on the
email said Twitter folks as if they were
best buddies and then they had the
secret what I call the super secret
James Bond teleporter app that they
could send messages to that would that
would you know go away and disappear
within a matter of weeks so they do all
this and they're telling them be on the
lookout for hack and leak operations I
think they they played Twitter and they
understood oh this is and and they were
a receptive audience you know like what
it must say 99 of them both Democrat and
getting Democrats so that was the
environment they didn't need the
specific email that said take down the
hunter Biden laptop story
um they were all primed to do it based
on what the FBI had done for months and
months meeting after meeting uh text
message or excuse me email after email
they were primed to do it and that's
what they did someone uh chatted just
now I think it's an important point they
said that we're not the uh we're not the
customers of big Tech with a product
it's a misunderstanding and I understand
the point the the real customer in a
true sense of trans a transactional
customer is the advertisers who are
buying access to data and access to an
audience but I think in a legal sense we
the users of Twitter are still customers
yeah there may not be a financial
transaction but there's a contract
between us as to what we get and in
exchange for the the policies in terms
of services I mean yeah that's it's a
contract it's a contractual agreement
yeah so I guess you know the challenges
I suppose we're seeing now is you know
look you guys may have gotten just a
modicum of of Power by by taking back a
few extra seats in the in the house
giving you this majority but is it
enough to create a long-standing impact
to pass laws to actually get something
done are these hearings going to be
enough to actually change things well I
mean look we hope so and all we can do
is is what we can do and you know we got
our first hearing tomorrow in the select
committee uh we hope this is a community
or excuse me a hearing that begins to
frame it up
um we're having Chelsea gabbard as one
of our Witnesses I think she'll be great
she's a True Believer in the First
Amendment we have a couple great
Senators Senator Grassley Senator
Johnson who've been investigated in some
of the things they told us that the
Democrats and these folks did to them
and FDI did to them so we think it'll be
a good hearing and then of course we
have on the second panel we have
Professor Turley who's who's op-ed out
this week I think is really good because
he used the term censorship by surrogate
and that's what we have now you got the
pressure from the government without
explicitly telling them to do certain
things at least we haven't found that
yet but that may we may find that but
the pressure from the government and
then the censorship from the tech
platforms
um is real and when you view it in this
in my mind you viewed in this bigger
framework of what we've seen the last
couple years I always tell folks every
single right we enjoy under the first
amendment has been assaulted in the last
couple years everyone you're right to
practice your faith your right to
petition the government right to
assemble freedom of press freedom of
speech speech being the most important
all of them have been attacked by the
government many of them in relation to
covet and the coveted policies but a
host of other things too and it's it's
really frightening you know what was the
craziest thing about all that too is
even the third amendment got violated
did you see that one the third amendment
the one that no one knows because no one
talks about is that the government can't
put soldiers in your house right because
this is back in the revolutionary period
and then when they did that yeah the
eviction moratorium effectively created
the circumstance in which uh active duty
soldiers who are renting property could
not be evicted in violation of the third
amendment they violated so much of the
Constitution they woke up the third it's
it's it's it's amazing it's kind of
scary at the same time I still remember
uh you know they the government told you
you couldn't go to church crazy I mean
the government said you couldn't come to
your own Capital that you pay for I mean
we're here in Capitol Hill now but you
couldn't come to Europe for like a year
and a half Nancy Pelosi wouldn't let you
in your Capital that you pay for to
petition your member of Congress to
redress your Grievances and the one I
always remember is is Jin saki standing
at the White House in The Press Room now
think about the White House is
considered the the center of freedom on
the planet here's the press secretary to
the United States uh to the president
United States in The Press Room and she
stands at the podium she says most
Americans now get their information from
social media platforms we the by the
ministration are working with social
media platforms to limit the information
Americans can see it was alive and I'm
like
did I just see that press secretary in
the Press White House Press briefing
room saying she wants to limit the Press
I mean like this is this is scary where
they share afford to go yeah they cheer
it on this is what I was uh I was saying
to congresswoman bobert a moment about
about an hour ago the way I view this is
with the manipulation of social media
the Restriction of information to the
American people the hunter Biden laptop
story right before an election being a
really prime example of this they've
created what I would describe as a
hypoxic portion of the United States
that is when when your brain is deprived
of oxygen you don't know you don't know
I don't know if you've ever seen these
videos but they're actually quite
revealing they'll put a person in in a a
seal chamber with a certain level of
oxygen and they'll slowly lower it while
asking them to answer basic math
questions to the person they're saying
one plus one is two two plus two is four
marble Boba Fitness 17
but in their mind they're saying
everything correctly really then they
play back the video for them and the
people are like what I was speaking
gibberish yet your brain had no oxygen
so you were slowly shutting down when
they deprive half this country of
information and these people get their
news and information from CNN or MSNBC
who have both just espoused so much
garbage we we have a situation where I
would describe it as half one the the
left hemisphere of our American
Consciousness is deprived of oxygen
unaware that it's for the past seven or
eight years been manipulated and just
deprived of facts but it's still voting
so how do we vote to correct a problem
when we are we are facing people who
don't know they're facing a problem and
they're voting continually to increase
that problem if you know what I mean no
I I I get it we do the best we can you
you pray for this great country you you
keep with a smile on your face like you
guys do you you keep giving the facts
and the truth ramp up the bout
harvesting yeah and you and you you play
into the rules like the rules of the
game are such that that you play under
those rules and you do it the best you
can uh and you play to win I have a
solution uh we could free the software
code of large social networks right now
instead of trying to break up the
companies force them once they get to a
certain number of users we treat it as a
Commons and the software code is
proliferated I think that's where I
think musk is thinking about doing that
I think that's where he may be headed we
could use government force and say you
know it's like a breaking up into
Monopoly but I
I think that would work and then you
Federate the networks and like my
version of Twitter and your version of
Twitter can see each other but if I want
to ban you on my network I can I still
have my my right as a as a business
owner to ban whoever I want but that
that would require a very large cultural
shift and it's and it's and it's
difficult but at the Run Mr pool thank
you hey man thanks for coming this is
absolutely fantastic I really do
appreciate it we gotta you got to come
to Ohio and see the the see the Jordan
chickens at some point oh yeah sounds
good man thanks man all right
all right uh we're gonna we're gonna
have uh congresswoman come in we'll do
some super chats
and uh man this is despite the fact that
the microphones aren't working I think
it's turning out pretty well huh
welcome back congresswoman so we have a
a plethora of super chats that I'll try
to uh
get as many as I can questions from the
audience and then we have uh
congresswoman Anna Paulina Luna yes yes
she's here yes she's here all right
we're gonna do this for a few minutes
and then we'll bring her in so
I want to find some good uh
questions let's see uh here I want to
make sure I'm finding some good super
chat questions that are directed
specifically for Congressman bobert Uh
Kevin Brady says can you ask Lauren if
she still supports Praying medic like
what she like what she's been doing but
we need a bit of clarity there I'm not
familiar Praying medic yeah are you
familiar with what that is no okay well
then all right then
you know we probably should do next time
is probably we should pull selects in
advance so we can uh make sure Joe Biden
does yeah just questions in advance well
I mean we have the chats coming in but
it's been an hour and a half yeah so
it's like I'm gonna try and scroll
through them and find some good ones for
uh
an oxygen deficiency in the White House
that's what's going on with Joe
for I think look I know that ample that
answer is way too simple you want me to
leave the client yes you want me to be
honest I don't know how you guys feel
about answering this but I've seen
pictures of his hand which look they
look like he has IV marks like they've
been giving him intravenous Solutions or
drugs
um and I have to imagine they do I also
am of the opinion that they give him
uppers I don't know if it's not
politically correct but he would be fast
last night at the State of the Union
um I mean so fast you stumbling over
everything and couldn't get it together
I mean I talk fast like that when I have
a big hearing because I just down to
Five Hour Energy so I don't know if
they're putting those through his veins
or what uh but my comms team can have
fun with that comment tomorrow
right on it's it's actually quite
difficult to go through all the super
chats in real time to find a good
question I might add so I'm doing my
best it's mostly people just saying
they're big fans to be completely honest
but uh let's let's do this we have uh
Turtle drums saying could you get each
guest's thoughts on auditing and or
ending the Federal Reserve and also the
Ian carbon stuff all right well uh a
couple questions in that regard the uh
the Federal Reserve I mean what are your
what are your thoughts we I think you
know Ron Paul wants to end it or at
least audit it many people have been
trying to audit the Federal Reserve
right no we absolutely have to start
with an audit uh and and see where that
goes but I I mean nothing that we're
doing financially is is working right
now I mean we're running on Monopoly
money
um so yeah an audit is a fantastic place
to start
and what about uh abolishing the ATF oh
um do you see my hat do you see this hat
here yeah no uh so I mean the ATF um I
think they need to come before Congress
and prove why they should be an agency
why the the things that they do that
maybe matter maybe there's something
that they do that matters I haven't
found it yet um but maybe that's sent
over to the FBI after you know we clean
them out but here's the problem with the
ATF
um they have they have gone beyond their
role of a regulatory agency and uh and
now they're making law they don't make
law congress makes law with these um
with with the pistol braces and um and
everything they're trying to do there to
make at least 10 million Americans
felons in in a very very short period
now the ATF they were the ones who ran
Fast and Furious they were giving
traced Firearms to known cartel members
and uh and they lost what 1700 of them
and these were these were were marked
fires to retract firearms and they lost
them and now they think they're going to
go after millions of Americans for a
firearm accessory and be successful with
that now I think there's going to be a
lot of boating accidents
um in America if if that's actually how
this goes down but I I'm hoping that the
courts strike this down entirely but
it's an abuse of the separation of
powers do you know if anyone any groups
have filed lawsuits over the ATF yeah
well and then I think it was the ninth
circuit um there was actually a pretty
big win there but um I mean it's got to
go beyond
um it has to go beyond that um to make
sure we can shut this down completely
but uh Congressman Matt Gates he has a
bill to abolish the ATF and uh you know
if they can't come before Congress and
answer and have um and us have oversight
over that agency
um and them answer to why they should
exist then heck yeah abolish them I
don't I don't believe the ATF has the
right to well the executive branch has
no legislative Authority no they cannot
declare this illegal but they are trying
to have legislate they're making law
right now the ATF is
um I mean Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms
that should be the name of a convenience
store you know it sounds like a good
time in my in my neck of the woods I I
heard about the pistol brace rule mm-hmm
when when the pistol brakes came up in
Congress it was actually in the
Judiciary Committee representative
sicilini
big old post
Al brace was and he was trying to
demonstrate that it turns any handgun
into a fully automatic if what no it
doesn't do this and these are these are
actual lawmakers trying to make laws
about them and they're completely
ignorant about them that's what I was
talking about like the hypoxia yeah like
they're deprived of information but
still desperately trying to do something
for some reason it just doesn't work
right yeah uh this this one really
really pissed me off when I heard this
and a lot of people were pissed off that
they just came out and said we hereby
decree something illegally we all
followed the law as you describe as it's
been described as it's been for for
decades and then abruptly a federal
agency just decided it is a criminal
offense now right that is not how no
laws are supposed to be passed in this
country absolutely not and uh even if a
law like that were passed I mean I would
hope that we would do everything that we
could to get it repealed
um to get it out of here uh Congressman
Matt Gates just walked in we're talking
about your bill abolish the ATF
right on let me look here's one we got
this one from Brandy says ask Byron and
Lauren where they get their jackets oh
this one um ooh I'm gonna sound so
squish
oh it's not Patagonia but it is
Lululemon oh is that what someone was
really interested in a lot of a lot of
the superchargers are saying that
they're big fans of of everybody's come
in Byron's the man Jim Jordan's the man
uh they they they let me know what you
do yeah yeah we uh this was cool very
last minute your your crew reached out
and said why don't you come and do it
here so we can get everyone out at the
same time and I was like that sounds
like the craziest thing we'll have ever
have done I got a super chat for you
here we don't know if I got a camera on
it oh here we got a different different
angle uh this is great this is from blah
blah Haskell BW Haskell amazing show we
need to Tim cast iron with reps from
both in parentheses all sides of the
aisle and let them have a long
respectful table conversation about the
issues the representatives on tonight
displayed great authenticity thanks from
between LA and San Diego
thank you Lauren thank you cool that was
a good one
yeah
yeah I think that having cross aisle
conversation is the future of politics
no absolutely and uh you know that's uh
that's something that uh Congressman
Matt Gates is is always um a a big
advocate for
um I mean take the speaker's debate
there was Dialogue on both sides of the
aisle for four days in the house
Chambers uh you know open debate and it
was amazing engaging with our colleagues
and that's something that I haven't seen
in Congress since I've been here until
then we have this real quickly I want to
read the thing it gave me hope that
those four days was like it inspired
hope in me that I haven't felt in
relation to our government in so long it
was yeah we got fundamental changes it
was totally worth the wait let me read
this one for you uh ew says Lauren I'm
an FFL and in an audit I had ATF agents
photograph every page of my Acquisitions
and disbursement logs we are required to
keep of our transfers this violates
regulations this is enough reason to
abolish the ATF this happens all the
time I'm with you I'm with you bring
them in um we're on the oversight
committee um bring them in and and make
them answer this stuff and I I don't see
any reason for ATF yeah but but we do
have uh congresswoman Anna Paulina Luna
here and I would love for her to get
some face time here on your show
um she's an amazing woman from Florida
went down and helped her during her
campaign
um I wanted I wanted Fighters here with
me in Congress and uh and we got her
here she's gonna interview her now like
like Byron didn't no no I'm just I was
just talking her up some uh you know
this is this is one of my freedom
fighters from the freedom caucus and she
and I serve on the natural resources
committee together and in the oversight
and accountability committee yeah
um I I mean it's on honor and privilege
as you can see we've been doing a lot of
work these last couple days and today
especially Lauren nuked the former
Twitter Executives on especially the
fact that they found out that obviously
you were being suppressed it was really
interesting to see them kind of squirm
but again I mean we know that this has
been taking place for a long time but I
think that the media was really
gaslighting and conservatives and I
think that they're they were censoring
anyone who really went against their
group think mentality
yeah no so it was so much fun um the
information that you brought out right
after I spoke was uh earth-shattering I
mean this was amazing the way you were
drilling
um these these Twitter Executives
um but I just found out last night from
Twitter staff uh that I was Shadow
banned I mean obviously we're seeing it
you know you see your numbers grow they
they drop back down you see the
suppression but there's no real evidence
and we found the date the time the tweet
and and it was happening it was real and
it was Mr Roth that would have had to um
have reviewed that and approved it and
he said that he didn't know anything
about it in committee I think you know
all of us who have larger accounts or or
high profile or doing Media or whatever
don't want to sound paranoid when it's
like hey I I tweeted something and no
one's retweeting it you don't want to
sound range yeah I know that was fire
where where's everybody at but then you
know you you come out and you're like
look I think I'm being Shadow banned
here and then people start saying no you
just suck then it turns out you're
actually being shadow actually and
you're actually pretty cool yeah but
that's that that's what seems to be
going but here's my frustration and I
want Anna to talk to I'm going to give
her my seat
um my frustration was not my account
personally it's the millions of
Americans who who can't reach out to
Elon Musk and his team and say hey what
actually happened here who can't sit in
a Committee hearing and hold these
people accountable
I'm able to do that that's great but
there's millions of Americans who were
completely silenced by the four people
that we had in the committee room and uh
you know AOC she put her little tweet
that I was there praising God for Elon
and yeah thank God for Elon Musk thank
God for him firing those four people and
and purchasing this crime scene as
Thomas Massey said and Jim Jordan uh
reiterated uh so he could expose
everything that's been going on but on I
want you I want to give you the hot seat
here so I'm going to switch with you all
right
thank you yeah just to kind of piggyback
off of what Lauren was saying so I
actually had to pull up this graphic to
make sure that I'm giving you guys
correct information but what we found
out is that uh Twitter the executives
and scissor which was under DHS so
really it was their um cyber security
infrastructure and Security Agency was
communicating on a private Cloud Server
to actually have people de-platform
their postings removed and the
interesting thing was is that when we're
in questioning yo Ross and then the rest
of the executives pretended like they
didn't know about it and we actually had
screenshots from the conversations mind
you this was done without any oversight
at all so they were operating in
darkness they're basically suppressing
this information from the American
people and what this is known as is a
joint State actor social media companies
to include Twitter were in this platform
but to be clear Facebook was also in it
and so what we uncovered was a pretty
big deal today I know that it actually
ties into what Laura Loomer has as an
actual lawsuit that she's currently
pursuing but this is a pretty big deal
and the fact that the government
agencies were communicating with Twitter
to interfere in free speech is a massive
deal not just for Republicans but for
everyone what about YouTube as of right
now I haven't been able to fully see
what's on the private server but we do
know for a fact that Facebook to include
anything owned by them so I assume also
Instagram and then also Twitter was in
this private Cloud Server and mind you
they are working with left-lining
organizations that were also to part of
the election Integrity partnership and
you can actually find this graphic on my
at rep API Luna website do you think
they lied today 100 yeah they lied to my
face wow they lied to my face they could
not recollect doing any of this so I
refresh their memory with the graphic
but the point is is that if we didn't
have that graphic mind you the graphic
was actually leaked on a Stanford
University YouTube video if we did not
find that we don't know that we would
actually been able to have proven this
information that jira existed and that
is a private software that they're
communicating on I think I think uh
Congressman Matt Gates is going to
interview you know
what's up uh this is the difference
between Lauren bobert and Matt gates for
me to get my chance to be on timcast I
had to drive into the middle of the
woods and you all
occur for the Lauren Melbourne
experience so I get the difference but
I'm I mostly came by because when I had
the chance to to go out to Tim castland
you said I was your favorite congressman
and I I firmly believe that that's
because you had not yet met Anna Paulina
Luna and so many of my colleagues who
were here but I was just glad to be on
because so many people I after you go on
Tim cast there's like this whole
experience where you get to read the
comments and all the great things people
say about Ian
and and what what I didn't appreciate
when I went on your show
is how many people who wear their name
on their shirt every day watch and when
I went out to events in my district the
law enforcement that provided security
said they watched him cast the the
teachers in the schools who are out
there fighting against the woke culture
and the critical race Theory say they
watch you and they get inspiration uh
the the folks who come out of the
kitchen at the restaurants where I ate
who were back there watching dishes and
slinging hash said you know we watched
him pool and when he said that he
thought you were a fighter we knew we
could believe it and it's a it was a
very powerful thing it was it was great
to spend time with you out in the
wilderness but quite something to see
how the people all over this country who
work hard and expect more out of their
government really believe in you and one
of the things we're fighting for on this
debt limit
work requirements
we got to have a strategy that unites
222 Republicans and you know what there
are times that's not the case there are
times when Anna and Lauren and Byron and
Jim Jordan and I have to go out on a
limb and engage in fights that nobody
else is willing to engage in but to deal
with the fact that our country has maxed
out our credit card debt and we have to
reflect on our spending habits as a
consequence means we got to have people
from center right from the perspective I
represent get together and what we've
been working on is to sell people on the
idea that if you can go to work
and you choose not to maybe you
shouldn't expect the other people who go
to work to pay for all your
you know your health care your
transportation your child care your cell
phone bill and so I appreciate the form
to be able to do that and that's the
next big fight we all we every great
General
fights the last war and we gotta fight
the next one and the next one is about
how we deal with this country's fiscal
crisis and I think there's there's no
greater cause that we that can unify us
than than the idea that
you should have to make a contribution
and in States like ours you know we're
Floridians and we're very proud
Floridians but in Florida when we tried
to seek waivers from the federal
government on things like food stamps to
do work requirements the federal
government said no over and over again
and if we just unlock the potential for
States be able to pursue these policies
my belief is that under our great
Federalist system the ideas that our
best will rise to the top and we'll see
them replicated and we got to create
that space so that's what we're working
on here in this building and good to
have you guys here right I'm in do you
want to
yeah I know I'm too too really max
credit and then also too with something
that happened during this speaker debate
is that um we actually had gotten a
commitment from leadership to ensure
that there would be no just blank check
spending for the debt ceiling and I
think that's important to note because
when you don't have these discussions
and you just simply go along to get
along these things won't get
accomplished so I feel like this
Congress granted I haven't been serving
that long but I do feel like this
Congress is a lot different than others
because of that and so it was an
accountability mechanism that needed to
happen and you guys will see it I mean I
can tell you and I support everything
that you just did this week regarding
Ukraine obviously no more blank checks
for Ukraine and I think that that needs
to be a more common sense approach you
know I hear a lot of people wanting War
but no peace talks and I think that we
can agree that we're not going to give
any more money to fund that that's not
our war it and when
people speak on behalf of our National
Defense we're talking about people like
Anna like her husband Andy who wore the
uniform who fought for our country Who
provided some of the most elite level
Talent you could ever muster for the
sake of a nation and when we talk about
having a rational defense budget we
don't for a moment mean that we ought to
surrender The High Ground to China or
limit the tools that our war Fighters
need but maybe all this 100 billion we
send to Ukraine
ought to get a little more scrutiny than
we have offered it and that's what I
think can at times unify the populist
right and the populace left and it's a
constant theme on your show and it's sad
to me how rare that occurs because there
are things like surveillance policy
foreign policy that could bring together
those elements and they've become so
strident in their desire to just wear
the blue shirt that they actually don't
represent some of the populist views
that that they once ran on when uh when
you came on last time you mentioned
potentially bringing on members of the
squad or to have a conversation
and uh I'm always down for a
conversation in that capacity but I
gotta be honest I don't find them to be
uh genuine I find them to be quite
disingenuous notably today uh I
mentioned it several times in the show
aoc's mentioning of the Boston
Children's Hospital lives of tick tock
just completely untrue and it seemed
like a performance for Twitter more than
actually getting to the root of these
issues with with Twitter uh you know I'm
talking about our Twitter followers
instead of asking calmly and reasonably
hey let me ask you about these
circumstances that we view to be you
know a problem there is an account that
we believe spread lies it's it's
bombastic it's performative it's
outrageous
and I just I don't trust it
well maybe they used to have more
optimism about their cross-sectional
appeal maybe when people like the squad
when they got elected they thought you
know what we can talk to more folks than
just the Democrat primary voters who
sent us here and this town wears you
down on that theory everything about
Washington is to divide and to separate
and make you believe that your only path
forward is with the people who wear the
color of your jersey and there are times
when we don't feel that way uh you know
Anna had to win her election to get here
beating the establishment The
Establishment went against her every
time she had to run against a lobbyist
her first time and I'll just tell you
this she will yes she will probably
confirm what I'm about to say but almost
every person in this town lined up
against Anna because oh she didn't know
Washington and she wasn't part of the
system in the game and I was a serious
candidate right it wasn't a serious
candidate and what I saw was someone who
actually if she got here was going to be
able to fight for her constituents
untethered from those corrupt influences
and while it took her to to uh two
elections to get here it's all the
sweeter actually to get someone here is
willing to fight The Establishment and
and you get that from people like Lauren
bobert who have to take out an incumbent
in a primary you get that from people
like Anna who have to take on an
establishment lobbyist literally to get
here and part of what we fought for in
that speaker fight was the opportunity
to bring more folks to Washington of
those experiences and to not have such a
concentrated influence of the UNA party
through the Pacs and the special
interests that no matter which political
party Republican or Democrat wins it's
always their people now we're starting
at some of our people here and glad you
were able to host a number of them
tonight I I really want to ask you Matt
about the you know the Kevin McCarthy
stuff because uh he said something
recently correct me if I'm wrong cause I
only saw a bit of the the Twitter
postings that the officer who shot
Ashley Babbitt was just doing her job he
had said previously he insinuations
about Donald Trump working for Russia
things like that and you know you stood
up to the establishment along with many
other members of Congress but you know
you were you were allowed you were vocal
it's one of the reasons I said you're my
favorite member because
I just I like seeing someone go to the
machine look I cheered for AOC when she
beat Crowley back in 2018 because I want
to see people tell the machine enough
you know knock it off I'm curious now on
your thoughts on speaker McCarthy he
gets elected he's uh you know he removes
Schiff and um swallow well from the
intelligence committee which I agree
with I I actually agree with your
initial argument on ilhan Omar that
removing her simply because she said
things you don't like doesn't seem to
make sense but uh how did you end up
going on you you ended up voting for her
removal
yeah I did I didn't feel good about it
to be honest with you I uh believed that
had ilhan Omar not voted to remove
Marjorie teller green and Paul gosar
from their committees that she would
have found a great deal more support uh
I think that was ultimately the decision
maker not just for me but probably for a
handful of members that you know if
you're gonna adopt this terrible
Paradigm and then you're not willing to
live by it that's actually the swamp
that's actually what we see too often
here and that hypocrisy had to be dealt
with in some way but here's what I know
if the normal rhythm of this place is
that every time power changes hands you
got to go nuke some of the loud people
on the other side who you don't agree
with it will actually be Lauren bobert
and Anna Paulina Luna and Matt Gates who
will get nuke next we have to understand
that and so I hope this ends It
ultimately what got me there look
McCarthy and Hakeem Jeffries both agreed
this has to end and I hope it ends at at
this standpoint the the Schiff and
swallow thing is very different because
they can be judged based on their acts
they took actions that hurt our country
by lying about intelligence I do not
believe that congresswoman Omar did that
I think she had made comments that upset
the various groups of people and that
that achieved a critical mass at some
point but sometimes we've got to listen
to the dissidents right sometimes we
have to be thoughtful and introspective
and reflective about what people say who
don't always align with the traditional
dogma of this place I I also too though
think that representative Perry brought
a great perspective which is ultimately
why I voted the way that I did which was
you know you have to be careful on the
speech aspect right because next cycle
if we don't have the gavel ultimately
they might say that something that we
said was offensive and wrong and try to
remove us from committees um so do be
clear she saw in committees but she also
did something that is really bad
especially when you're on Foreign
Affairs and that is that she all getting
inside
um basically had engaged in Immigration
fraud and so I think that when people
are being looked at for their committees
what they bring to the table I think
that that's an important note yeah but
by what standard okay by what standard
what what we because there were some
news articles we automatically assume
that's the truth I mean there were a lot
of news articles about me that were
false right and so I I have a higher
standard for due process than that we
have an Ethics Committee and we have an
ethics rule that says that if you bring
discredit on the house by your actions
that then you can be expelled from this
institution and that we are ultimately
the Arbiters of our own membership and
so I don't know the fact that we remove
somebody without that due process I I do
believe that a number of us Scott
speaker McCarthy to agree that in the
future there has to be some ability for
people to appeal and and have a
potential removal examine more
thoroughly
but you know there were a lot of
Republicans who were waving their
pom-poms about that vote I cast the vote
I do believe on committee membership the
speaker deserves deference but if this
becomes a situation where we cancel
people in the Congress on committees
based on their perspective on certain
things that don't align with the
traditional Dogma then I'm probably the
next one on The Chopping Block so I got
a question for both of you uh how would
you rate speaker McCarthy's performance
thus far I would give speaker McCarthy
an a I would and he has kept his
commitments he has reaffirmed his
commitments I am eager to get the 14 000
hours of January 6 footage out and if
you had been in some of the depositions
I've been in these last few days with
FBI officials getting that information
out is critically important our
weaponization subcommittee has already
begun the process of collecting
documents and interviewing
whistleblowers and
I I am deeply concerned about the extent
to which that undercover Federal
officers and confidential informants
that were working for the federal
government could have animated some of
the criminal Acuity of that day
um also too for those who are looking
and watching this right now I actually
spoke to speaker McCarthy's office and
he said that if you do have a case and
that you feel that footage might
actually help your case to prove that
you are innocent that they will actually
work to get that footage to you so to
contact your member of Congress and then
they can work to do that so I think that
for people watching obviously there are
many different circumstances and so
people deserve to write have the right
to defend themselves and they deserve
the right to access to that footage and
they have that now well just look at the
today today we passed a Thomas Massey
bill that carried with it a Lauren
bobert substantive Amendment this is the
type of stuff that you would not have
seen in a traditional Congress where the
people who have access to the floor and
the amendatory process are those who are
blessed by the lobbyists and speaker
McCarthy to his great credit was willing
to give the power back to the members
and ameritocracy develops as a
consequence of that that you don't get
when it's just about who writes the
checks
so does it feel like at least for you
guys the people are starting to win back
control
yeah I mean listen think about just that
question from one of the last questions
you asked me when I was on your program
you said Gates how worried are you about
retribution
that was yours your your belief was that
what we the the force that we had
brought on this place would result in us
being punished and instead it's our
amendments our bills our ideas that are
driving the discussion and you know what
we're not going to win them all
we're going to get beat sometimes on the
floor on the ideas we present like when
Marjory Taylor green put an idea up to
limit the president's ability to just
issue an emergency over everything and
everything that lost but we're actually
willing to take votes on amendments that
lose and I think that that brings the
American people into the discussion in a
far more fruitful way what about uh
what's up with that demolishing the IRS
well I believe we should have the fair
tax I believe the American people should
be able to choose how much taxes they
pay based on their consumption and if
you want to go buy a Lamborghini or some
like crazy expensive skateboard that
some dude you know makes in his garage
then all the better but then you can pay
the taxes on that and what frustrates us
is that oftentimes we're just funding
the bureaucracy it's not even like we're
extracting money from the American
people to go to their needs we're
extracting it to fund a system that
picks winners and losers and the
powerful and the elite and the connected
get get access to that system so so
let's uh I'll give you a hypothetical if
um we could probably very difficult to
do but let's say we were able to isolate
specifically bloated bureaucracy
spending if we could take all of that
money and apply it to Health Care
government spending that money instead
on helping people with Health Care would
you be in favor of that well I I
absolutely would but but let's look at
the VA which is something that Anna and
I have talked about at Great length not
just in the policy space but as it
literally relates to you know our our
families and the people we love if we
abolished the VA and gave every veteran
a card that allowed them to get fee for
service at any health care provider that
they walked into in this country and if
you want to provide Health Care in this
country you better be willing to provide
it for to a veteran for the amount that
we would pay for it at that rate then
you could eliminate the bureaucracy and
you could spend all the money that is
appropriate to that bureaucracy actually
on health care for veterans yeah if I if
that was an option today I guarantee
most vets would go that route and one of
the most frustrating things is that
especially during what happened with
covid because of the bureaucracy a lot
of veterans that did need help
especially that had PTSD that needed to
talk to doctors weren't getting the help
that they needed but but if we're gonna
do Universal Health Care which is the
essence of your question
in exchange for
bureaucratic inertia and bureaucratic
waste there's no more fruitful space
than the VA and no more meritorious
space
yeah I mean he he nailed it again
um systems like the VA and mind you
service members do essentially pay into
that and so that's a friendly reminder
to people a lot of people say well the
military has socialized health care but
we are literally paying back into that
system so for me from that perspective I
mean there's so much broken with the VA
president Trump did a lot of good but
there's still so much that needs to be
fixed with it and so I just anyone that
ever advocates for socialized medicine
I'm like you guys have no idea what
you're starting oh yeah I'm I'm I'm also
very glad that this time I get to talk
to you my voice actually works I was
like thanks for coming the magic of the
last episode was that you couldn't talk
and that Ian was giving us brilliant
take after brilliant take
surge even got in the action yes
say this here we are because I want to
ask you and both you guys really what do
you guys think about like setting up an
application or an app or something where
people could allocate a portion of their
taxes like a sliding thing where you're
like okay first of all it's like a well
I'll say Tinder like you swipe right if
you like this this idea they want to
build a fountain on main street and then
you go into your little thing you can
slide I want to put three percent of my
discretionary tax money towards the
fountain and this and that and then
you've got like you have to do 10
minimum for the police 10 for the fire
department 30 for black budget military
because what the heck you know you get
you get some control you get some
control over your tax where you put your
taxes and then maybe the system can sort
itself out
yeah I uh I think that that would
convert our
Republic to a direct democracy right and
that's what you're talking about you're
talking about direct Democratic inputs
to the Appropriations process and
I don't know I I it's crowdsourcing the
Appropriations process we had to look
we're just trying to crowdsource the
Appropriations process among the elected
representatives and we about had to burn
this place to the ground
extortionist terrorists I mean
everything yeah but I uh you know I I'd
have to think about that and it could be
like an amalgam like a uh like the
blockchain or something so that it's
every and then we could view it at any
time right so make sure that they're not
fixing it on the back end I have it on
like nine different blockchains at once
yeah
no so I think we're about to go private
here in just a minute um so uh I just
want
um Matt to really give the perspective
of Anna as a freshman going into the
speaker fight because that is absolutely
massive I mean she came in like a boss
and said no I know this place is broken
I ran on Congress being broken and I'm
here to fundamentally change it so for
those of you who are going private
you'll you'll get some exclusives on
that yeah this has been awesome so we're
gonna we're gonna try and get this uh
members only segment up we had four
microphones planned apparently only two
of them worked but I think we made
something work and I'm really excited
this is awesome uh you know a couple
days ago bobert's team reached out and
said can we do a show here so we can get
everybody in and it was perfect timing
with the state of the union with the
Twitter stuff so it'd be really awesome
maybe maybe next time and there will be
next time we'll uh we'll build the
system for a mobile setup well in
advance because I think we only had like
three days to try and build a whole
system to drive in a car and set it up
but I think it'll be even better next
time what we'll do now is we will uh go
to the members only segment so become a
member at timcast.com go to timcast.com
click join us and in about one hour
we're gonna have a uncensored members
only show and I just want to mention you
know Matt Gates comes in and he's
swearing already so maybe maybe it'll be
a bit more exciting than it already was
very very fun
so uh smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends you can follow me at Tim you can
follow the show at timcast IRL you can
follow me personally at timcast uh
congresswoman Luna do you want to shout
anything out
um yeah Matt Gates was one of the only
representatives to actually uh even talk
to me during my initial race and then
came down and helped me and so I
actually owe him a lot for being here so
Matt's probably why I dove into the
speakers race the way that I did I trust
trust in Matt right on I don't know if
uh uh congresswoman bobert or Gates do
you want to say anything before you wrap
up and go to the private segment
folks
hey I just uh I'm so grateful for for
everyone joining today
um welcome to my congressional office uh
it's in total disarray right now
um but my family's been in in the
background of your shots the whole time
so
um Tim thanks so much for coming out
here you know we we are doing amazing
things up here in in our slim majority
we don't have the Senate we don't have
the white house but we are Paving the
way
um for policies that will actually work
when we do get these things uh back and
we have that control again so we can
really get America back on track that's
why I'm here I'm here so my four boys
three of them are running around they
were just uh Wheeling chairs and having
races out in the hallway uh I'm here so
my my boys will not live in a socialist
nation and uh you know being a mom of
four boys you know I I'm not raising
them to be children I'm not raising them
to be little boys I'm raising them to be
men and that is so dang important right
now when liberals are trying to teach
them to be women so uh yeah there's a
lot to fight for in this country but um
Jesus is Lord and I'm so happy to live
in this in this free country and I do
have hope if I didn't I would go home
well thank you so much for allowing us
to use your office so we could have so
many awesome people come down and talk
to not only everybody watching but that
we we got the opportunity to talk to all
of you as well so just one more thing to
stress I see a lot of people are are
becoming YouTube members but the members
only show will be at timcast.com on the
left side you'll see a join us you click
that you sign up there and then we're
going to upload this you'll see it on
the front page of the website in about
one hour so I will leave it there thank
you all so much for hanging out and for
for supporting us thus far and for being
members and stick around we should have
this members only show coming up for you
in about an hour and we'll see you all
there